So, da bin ich. Oh, ich höre schon. Moment, Teams hat wieder rumgestellt.
Habe ich schon mal gesagt, dass Teams einfach extrem sackt, wenn das einfach an den Audio-Settings rumdoktert, ohne dass man das will?
PP-Hands? Naja, so groß hat es gar nicht rumgespielt, so ist es besser.
This device is currently in use. Oh nein! Anzeige ist raus. Warum ist das einfach in use?
Könnte sein, weil ich da gerade reinrede. Möglich, möglich wäre es.
Moin, Kreos-Krieger. So, Twitch hat noch nicht gecheckt, dass das Stream online ist. Das ist nice.
Twitch ist manchmal mega schnell und manchmal übelst langsam. Hat bestimmt noch ein bisschen was mit der Uhrzeit zu tun, wann man streamt.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt mal warten. Da sind wir noch kaputt hier unten.
Ich muss jetzt mal warten, bis Twitch gecheckt hat, dass das Stream richtig on ist.
Ja, ich überlege.
Kann ich euch in der Zwischenzeit, bis Twitch gecheckt hat, falls irgendjemand das Wort gucken sollte?
Der kann jetzt ja nicht im Chat schreiben, aber trotzdem, falls jemand da ein Wort gucken sollte, kann ich euch irgendwas Spannendes erzählen?
Lass mal kurz überlegen. Gibt es irgendwas, womit ich die Zeit überbrücken könnte, bis die Leute da sind und die Notifications bekommen haben?
Moin, Fips.
Hm, gab es irgendeine... Ja!
Ich habe heute, glaube ich, die...
Mit die... Zweimal, Leute.
Ich wurde heute zweimal versucht, allein am Tag, zweimal versucht zu fischen.
Zu fischen, wurde ich... Haben sie mich heute versucht zu...
Fischen.
Und zwar...
Einmal...
Habe ich eine Phishing-Mail gekriegt.
Aber ich glaube, die eine habe ich auf...
Die eine habe ich auf...
Twitter...
gepostet.
Also, obviously...
Wie hat Unge mal was geschrieben?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ich würde gerne meinen...
Zeug hier...
Einen Twitter...
Also, ich habe heute...
Vom... Legit...
Vom offiziellen YouTube-Support...
Wieder...
Von Javed...
Rahman...
Habe ich heute vom offiziellen YouTube-Support wieder ein Copyright-Warning-Strike bekommen.
Legit.
Mit Sicherheit.
Also, das muss der echte...
Der echte Rahman...
Oder Javed...
Ich glaube, Javed ist der richtige Vorname.
Das muss der echte...
Javed Rahman vom YouTube-Support sein.
1786.
Ich glaube, das kann...
Nicht fake sein.
So, also...
Damit wurde ich heute Morgen schon mal versucht zu fischen.
Und dann habe ich auf der Arbeit noch heute...
Es ist Premiere.
Ich habe noch nie eine Phishing-Mail auf der Arbeit bekommen.
Habe ich auf der Arbeit die schlechteste Phishing-Mail aller Zeiten bekommen.
Die ist wirklich mega schlecht.
Moment.
Aber auf Deutsch.
Aber auf Deutsch immerhin.
Oh, Mist.
Ich dab.
Ich habe die schon gelöscht.
Warte mal.
Mal gucken, ob die noch bei mir im...
Ah, shit.
Papierkorb.
Hier.
Laura Müller hat mir geschrieben auf der Arbeit.
Laura Müller.
Liebe Grüße von meinem Arbeitsplatz.
Und ich meine auf Deutsch.
Es war schon ein bisschen gezielteres Phishing.
Und unten drunter ist so ein super verpixeltes Bild, wo steht...
Hier bin ich übrigens.
So ein verpixeltes Bild.
Und dann kann man das anklicken auf einem...
Passt mal auf.
Haltet euch fest.
wetransfer.com.
Link.
Legit.
Seriously.
Ganz sicher.
Irgendeine random Laura schickt mir irgendein gefaktes PDF auf wetransfer.com.
Natürlich.
Die Laura vom Wendler.
Genau.
Moment.
Heißt die...
Heißt die nicht sogar Laura Müller?
Die vom Wendler?
Heißt die nicht so?
Ich bin da nicht so im Bild.
Aber ich glaube, die heißt so, oder?
Ja, ich glaube auch.
Genau.
Das wird...
Das wird so sein.
Die hat keinen Bock mehr auf den Wendler und will jetzt DevOps stelzen.
Das wird sein, Chat.
Glaube ich auch.
Ich glaube auch.
Ich glaube, die Mail ist echt.
Aber ich muss die Musik...
Auch wenn es da ist, muss ich es ein bisschen leiser machen.
Die Playlist kann sich wieder nicht entscheiden, was er machen will.
Ja.
Ja, also zweimal richtig billige Phishing-Mails heute bekommen.
Wobei das natürlich keine Phishing-Mail ist.
Das ist bestimmt der echte YouTube-Support.
Direkt von Fiverr.
Was trendet denn in Deutschland?
Ich will das eigentlich gar nicht wissen, was in Deutschland trendet.
Sponsor.
Dackel.
Traumjob.
Übergriffig.
Wahlsieger.
Trump.
Gutachter.
Deep Pitch Mode.
Wie spricht man die?
Das ist ja eine Band.
Selensky.
Ich dachte, den schreibt man mit Z.
Und Lehrerin.
Wir hatten in der Berufsschule...
Ach Mist.
Vergiss.
Ich habe das Wort verdreht.
Aber ich erzähle es jetzt trotzdem mal.
Damit es sich nicht ganz so bescheuert anhört, was ich erzähle.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wir hatten eine in der Berufsschule.
Die hat für ein Erotik-Portal gearbeitet.
Als Admin.
Als Admin, ja.
Ich kann mich falsch verstehen, als Admin.
Und die hat bei kollegien.de gearbeitet.
Und irgendwie habe ich bei Lehrerin gerade an Kolleginnen gedacht.
Frag mir nicht.
Und ist mir das wieder eingefallen.
Und was die da teilweise erzählt hat, da fällt es dir echt vom Glauben, von der Menschheit ab, ey.
Die hat zum Beispiel einmal erzählt, dass die verschiedene...
Ich muss jetzt gucken, dass ich nicht zu viele Details...
Erzähle, ja.
Wir sind ja immerhin auf Twitch.
Die hat erzählt, dass sie irgendwie so eine Tag-Datenbank haben.
Und dass die Leute dort ihre Videos halt taggen können, je nach Vorlieben und Fetisch, ja.
Und da hat sie halt mal erklärt, so mit was sie sich auseinandersetzen muss.
Was sie halt wissen musste, was jeder Tag irgendwie zur richtigen Einordnung, was jeder Tag bedeutet.
Das heißt, die musste dann wirklich sich durchlesen, was die Bedeutung hinter jedem Tag auf...
Auf so einer Erotik-Seite ist.
Hat auch gemeint, also, ihr wart nicht klar, was es alles gibt, und vieles davon will sie eigentlich überhaupt nicht wissen.
Ich auch nicht, ich auch nicht, ja.
Aber Admin bei einer Erotik-Seite möchte ich auch nicht sein.
Da musst du dich...
Überlegt euch mal, was da für eine Scheiße hochgeladen wird.
Ich meine, ich will auch garantiert nicht Content-Mod auf YouTube, Facebook oder sonst wie sein.
Da kannst du ja nach einem halben Jahr nur psychische Störungen davontragen.
Aber bei einer Erotik-Seite...
Im Erotik-Portal erst recht auch nicht, weil da wird noch...
Also, da wird vieles abartiges Zeug hochgeladen, was aber noch nicht illegal ist.
Und dann auch noch freigeschaltet werden muss und sowas.
Boah, Alter.
Boah, da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Nee, nee, das muss echt nicht sein.
Du hast letztens aus Frankreich eine SMS bekommen, dass ich doch bitte 3,99€ Zoll an dir Helm überweisen soll.
Das bekomme ich mal wirklich nicht.
Naja, ganz so weit von der Realität weg ist es ja auch nicht.
Man bekommt ja manchmal...
Manchmal vom Zoll irgendwelche Nachrichten.
Die sind dann aber nicht per SMS aus Frankreich oftmals.
Allerdings, die...
Also, die schlechtesten Erfahrungen, was das angeht, habe ich tatsächlich mit dem Zoll-DHL in Leipzig gemacht.
Weil, wenn man aus den USA was bestellt, dann landet das höchstwahrscheinlich in Leipzig.
Weiß nicht, ob da so die Hauptabfertigungsstelle ist oder so.
Und die waren so unglaublich langsam.
Und die waren so unglaublich unhilfreich.
Und die Leute am Telefon waren so hilflos.
Du hast dir gedacht, Mann, wo bin ich da gelandet?
Express, Express-Paket.
Ich habe die extra bezahlt dafür, dass die das abwickeln mit dem Zoll.
Das hat irgendwie drei oder vier Wochen ewig hat es gedauert.
Wobei das natürlich nicht...
Äh, den Zoll musst du beim Paketboten bezahlen.
Ne, den Zoll kannst du auch beim Zoll bezahlen.
Das gibt... Das geht auch.
Ich war auch schon beim Zoll und habe dort direkt was bezahlt.
Ich habe beim Zoll...
Ich glaube, die Story...
Gut, dass der Chainer nicht da ist.
Da könnt ihr wieder recycelt, recycelt Story spammen.
Das Highlight bei mir beim Zoll ist gewesen...
Ich habe mir eine Background-LED-Beleuchtung für den Fernseher bestellt.
Hier.
Tream...
Warte mal.
Ist das Treamlight?
Ne, ähm...
Tream...
Ich habe vergessen, wie das Ding hieß.
Oh, es hieß doch Treamlight.
Treamscreen.
Ich habe mir sowas bestellt.
Das sind im Endeffekt so Ambilights zum Nachrüsten.
So, und in Wirklichkeit sind das LED-Strips.
Man sieht es jetzt...
Ja, hier, guck mal.
Ne.
Ja, hier sieht es so aus.
Es ist im Prinzip...
Ist das eine Steuerung?
Ist das ein Controller mit LED-Strips?
Und...
Ja, also da sieht man es im Endeffekt.
Es ist ein Controller mit LED-Strips gewesen.
Und das ist beim Zoll gelandet, weil es die Amis ja wieder nicht hingekriegt haben, das ordentlich zu deklarieren.
Ist das beim Zoll gelandet?
Und beim Zoll musste ich dann aufmachen und er hat dann eine Tabelle rausgeholt, was es denn jetzt eigentlich ist.
Weil ich habe ihm erzählt, das ist eine Beleuchtung, das ist eine LED-Hintergrundbeleuchtung für den Fernseher.
Und dann hat er gemeint so, hm, okay, Fernseher.
Und dann guckt er in seine Tabelle und meinte, sucht dann halt so diese in der Tabelle raus, das für Fernsehgeräte.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Leute, das Paket war so groß wie ein Xbox-Controller oder so jetzt.
Nicht sonderlich groß, ja.
Und dann meinte er wirklich, Fernsehgeräte.
Und ich meinte, nein, das ist kein Fernseher.
Das ist eine Beleuchtung für einen Fernseher.
Das ist kein Fernsehgerät.
Ja, aber was ist denn das jetzt?
Das haben wir hier nicht draufstehen.
Alter, das war, also der Besuch im Zoll war wirklich negativ Highlight, was ich hatte.
Ich war schon öfters beim Zoll, in letzter Zeit nicht mehr, weil ich mittlerweile weiß, was man machen muss, dass man nicht beim Zoll landet.
Nämlich das Beste ist schon mal nicht aus den USA bestellen.
Wenn ihr nicht aus den USA bestellt, das was da heute steht, stimmt nicht.
Wenn ihr schon mal nicht aus den USA bestellt, dann ist das schon mal nicht aus den USA bestellt. Das was da heute steht, stimmt nicht.
Wenn ihr schon mal nicht aus den USA bestellt, dann ist das schon mal nicht aus den USA bestellt.
Könnt ihr davon ausgehen, dass das meiste landet nicht beim Zoll?
Weil die anderen Länder bekommen es irgendwie hin, die Sachen auszuzeichnen, nur Bestellungen aus den USA kriegen sie irgendwie nicht gebacken.
Ich habe so oft schon bei den China-Chinesen bei AliExpress bestellt, Leute.
Also ich glaube, neben Amazon dürfte eine Zeit lang, also nicht insgesamt, aber eine Zeit lang, dürfte AliExpress meine zweitmeistbesuchteste Shoppingseite gewesen sein.
sein. Nicht in letzter Zeit. In letzter Zeit
habe ich tatsächlich relativ wenig bestellt
bei AliExpress. Aber es
gab Zeiten, da habe ich bei AliExpress
fast so viel bestellt wie
bei Amazon. Gerade als ich Elektronik-Kram
gebastelt habe.
Und bei denen
ist noch nie, ernsthaft noch nie,
was im Zoll gelandet. Und was witzig ist,
die Leute haben immer übelst
Probleme, so
das kann ich nicht in China bestellen, das landet
im Zoll. Aber bestellen in den USA, wo
es sicher im Zoll landet, weil es die Amis nicht gebacken
kriegen. Also eins muss man den AliExpress
versendern lassen. Entweder
schaffen die das gut
zu kennzeichnen, so dass es nie beim Zoll
landet. Oder die haben verschiedene andere
Tricks, dass es nicht beim Zoll landet. Fragt
mich nicht. Zumindest
ist bei AliExpress noch nie
bei mir jemals was im Zoll gelandet.
Zumal die es ja auch geschickt machen.
Die schicken das Ganze ja
oftmals aus EU-Warenlagern
oder aus Spanien.
Also, oder aus
den Niederlanden. Also, ich weiß, AliExpress
hatte eine ganze Zeit lang irgendeinen so
exklusiven Vertrag mit PostNL.
Mit der niederländischen Post.
Die haben doch da auch irgendwie in Amsterdam
oder Rotterdam, Rotterdam wahrscheinlich,
die Schiffe angekommen. Dann hatten sie
teilweise größere Lager in Spanien
und ich glaube, sie haben jetzt auch im
östlichen Europa
irgendwas und UK und Frankreich.
Also, die sind überall. Dann hat sich
das natürlich mit Zoll erledigt an der Stelle.
Für mich als Endverbraucher.
Für die nichts.
Ja.
Ich habe heute ein Ersatzteil
von FlexiSpot bekommen.
Ach, geht doch.
Ersatzteil? Hast du so einen FlexiSpot-Tisch,
den ich mal vorgestellt habe, oder was hast du?
Traugen die was, oder würdest du nicht
mal bestellen? Du meinst die Dreamlight?
Du meinst den...
Ne, DreamScreen?
Das meinst du?
Hintergrundbeleuchtung?
Die würde ich nicht mal bestellen,
weil die gibt es nicht mehr. DreamScreen ist pleite
gegangen.
Es gibt allerdings Alternativprodukte.
Da weiß ich nicht, wie die sind.
Ich kann dir zum DreamScreen sagen,
dass der für ein Gerät aus dem Jahr
2000...
Ich habe das schon eine ganze Weile.
Ich sage jetzt einfach mal 2014,
2015. Ich habe das wirklich schon
lang, den Kram.
Gucken, vielleicht habe ich...
Habe ich das ja damals auf
Twitter geschrieben? Ne.
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Okay, also ich habe das schon
eine ganze Weile.
Also für ein Produkt aus dem Jahr, sagen wir mal so
2015 rum, waren die wirklich gut.
Ich habe das immer noch im Einsatz.
Funktioniert immer noch.
Einzige Problem, was ich habe, meins funktioniert
nicht mit 4K
und hat Probleme
mit HDR.
Da gab es zwischenzeitlich
neuere Versionen für 4K
und HDR.
Allerdings
kein DreamScreen mehr. Aber du kannst mal gucken, es gibt
jede Menge ähnlicher Ersatz
für DreamScreen.
Und an sich kann ich wirklich empfehlen, ist
mega nice. Gerade wenn man wie ich
im Wohnzimmer
Max FPS
Wo sieht man mein Wohnzimmer?
Mein Wohnzimmer?
Hier. Genau.
Ja, ja. Hallo Jungs und Mädels.
Man sieht es nicht so wirklich gut.
Aber ich habe hinterm Fernseher
halt weiße Wand.
Das wäre übrigens
für einen Beamer im Prinzip
auch gar nicht schlecht.
Das habe ich mir auch schon überlegt, aber da müssen wir ein bisschen
rumbasteln. Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Also jetzt hier, ich habe eine weiße Wand.
Man sieht es nicht. Ich habe es zu sehr auf meinem Fernseher
gesumt. Aber man
sieht ja im Hintergrund, dass
es weiße Wand ist.
Mega schlechte
Auflösung, ne?
So und da ist
es halt wirklich, wirklich cool.
Ich weiß,
es ist leider zu hell.
Weiß nicht, ob ich hier mal dunkel
gemacht habe.
Ein bisschen erkennt man es vielleicht im
Hintergrund. Es hat kaum Delay und so.
Also ich kann es wirklich empfehlen. Es ist eine gute Sache.
Auch die Alternativprodukte,
wenn die ähnlich sind, würde ich empfehlen.
Ja.
Wie lange noch Defop stellt, bis Resturlaub ansteht?
Ähm.
Wahrscheinlich so bis hier.
Also ungefähr noch
eineinhalb Monate.
Ungefähr noch eineinhalb Monate.
Dann habe ich Resturlaub.
So eineinhalb Wochen.
Und dann geht es ab 1. März
geht es los.
No Puffs.
1. April, ja.
Am 1. April geht es dem neuen Job los.
Genau.
Also wie gesagt, ich kann es dir trotzdem empfehlen.
Guck dir mal
die Alternativprodukte an. An sich ist es eine super
Sache, gerade wenn man
eine einheitlich
gefärbte, ohne irgendwie großartige Sachen
Wand hinter dem Fernseher hat,
macht es das viel angenehmer zu gucken.
Ah.
Ach tatsächlich, okay.
Aber es ist gut, dass es dann relativ schnell ist.
Weil es Ersatzteile gibt.
Da habe ich doch keine Werbung gemacht für totalen Müll.
Ja, das machen wir heute übrigens nicht.
Tja.
So sieht es aus. Ansonsten gab es die Woche
noch irgendwas Spannendes. Ich bin gerade am
am überlegen.
Ach ja Leute, ich habe heute übrigens
auf Twitter
ähm
auf Twitter habe ich heute wieder gelernt, wenn man
Kritik äußert an einer Programmiersprache.
Was ist denn hier los?
Warum geht Nitter nicht?
Ist Nitter broken?
Was ist da los?
Warum ist es kaputt?
Oh, es ist kaputt anscheinend.
Äh, Twitter.
Ich habe heute
eine Sache auf Twitter.
Twitter hat die API eingestellt.
Nein, ernsthaft.
Wirklich?
Gibt es auch narrow people sad?
Wir sind, nein, nein, nein.
Sad
reicht schon.
Ach, die haben das komplett
eingestellt. Wirklich?
Okay, die kostet was.
Ja gut, das können die sich aber nicht leisten.
Das ist ja eine Seite, die kein Geld verdient damit.
Die können wahrscheinlich die API-Requests gar nicht bezahlen.
Den Tweet, der mich beleidigt hat?
Echt, mich hat einer beleidigt
im Tweet? Den habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Post, poste mal. Weiß ich gar nicht.
Ähm, nee, was ich meine ist,
ich habe doch letztens geschrieben,
die kostet 150 Euro,
500 Request.
Hahaha.
Das ist ja krass, Alter.
Das ist Absicht, oder?
Um zu sagen, wir haben sie nicht
abgeschafft, aber faktisch hat man sie abgeschafft.
Also, ich habe nach
meinem letzten Python-Stream
etwas versucht, meine
Kritik an der Sprache, die mir
so als, ist nicht übelster
Python-Crack, aber jemand, der
seine Kenntnisse aufgefrischt
hat, habe ich mal versucht, in so einem Tweet
zusammenzufassen.
Und
darauf waren natürlich dann Leute
etwas teilweise getriggert.
Was mich wundert, man kann auch getriggert sein
für Programmiersprachen.
Zum Beispiel, wobei das hier
wette ich mit euch, das ist
Gbait. Das ist Gbait.
Der meint das nicht ernst.
Bei dem bin ich mir
zu 99% sicher, dass es Gbait ist.
Allein schon,
wie sich das liest, Python-Noobs
at its best. Zen of Python
nicht verstanden. Tippe stark darauf, dass du
allgemein noch nie an großen Softwareprojekten
gearbeitet hast, geschweige denn
nennenswerte Programmiererfahrung. Arbeite
seit 4 Jahren damit, die Verbreitung spricht für sich.
Also, das ist Gbait. Da bin ich mir
relativ sicher.
Heute hat noch ein anderer geschrieben. Den fand ich
auch lustig. Hier. Also, das
hier gar keine Frage. Der sagt halt, okay,
aber ist
this jetzt wirklich so viel besser als
self? Na, ihr wisst ja,
in Java und C Sharp und so ist es
this. In Python ist es
self. Ist im Prinzip
das gleiche. So.
Habe ich gesagt, naja, eigentlich ist eher das Problem, dass
man an allen Ecken und Enden
Python nutzen muss. So, und jetzt kommt er.
Jetzt, jetzt, ja, habe ich ein Beispiel. Also, zum Beispiel
self.underscore
underscore name anstatt
underscore name. So, und jetzt, und jetzt
kommt er. Jetzt kommt er. Der Beste. Der Beste
hier. Das ist ein Problem,
wenn man versucht, Gewohnheiten von anderen
Sprachen auf Python zu übertragen. Speziell
das underscore underscore siehst du in
Pythonischem Code praktisch nie.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen, der offizielle
Styleguide
spricht von underscore und underscore
underscore. Der offizielle, also nicht
wie so ein random Dude auf Twitter,
der offizielle Styleguide sagt das.
Ähm, und
mal ganz davon abgesehen, es hat mit self nix
zu tun, weil self brauchst du immer
noch, wenn du auf Klasseninstanz, also auf
Instanzvariablen referenzieren
willst. Ob da jetzt
ein minus minus, äh, ein underscore underscore steht,
ist egal.
So, und jetzt kommt aber das Beste.
Jetzt kommt aber das Beste.
Self weglassen zu
können, würde auch nicht zum
Konzept von Python passen.
Implicit is better than implicit. Okay,
soweit in Ordnung, soweit in Ordnung.
Aber jetzt kommt's. Mehr funktional
programmieren, dann braucht man nicht so viel
selbst. Also sprich, auf gut Deutsch,
just don't use it
for it. Oder was,
was soll mir denn diese Message jetzt sagen,
man? Es ist ja nicht so, als hätte
ich mir das ausgedacht, dass ich an der Stelle
das ganze OOP-Style machen
muss. Das war halt diese,
das ist halt, die Plugin-Module
musst du halt so machen.
Aber
was ist das für ein Argument?
Ja, dann benutzt das halt nicht in
der Sprache, dann ist es auch kein
Problem. Ja, nach der Logik
könnten wir auch sagen, mach doch alles,
mach doch alles im Hex-Editor,
wenn man fehlerfrei programmieren kann,
braucht man doch auch sonst keine richtige
Programmiersprache.
Also mit der Logik kannst du ja alle, also mit dieser
Nicht-Logik kannst du
alles irgendwie kontern.
Du brauchst aber trotzdem,
ja, Moment, in C-Sharp macht man
das so? Da gibt es so eine, so eine, so eine
ungeschriebene Regel,
dass man private Instanzvariablen, dass man
die Underscore nennt,
aber in Python musst du trotzdem
Underscore, musst du trotzdem
self Punkt schreiben, wenn
du auf irgendwelche Instanzklassenvariablen
referenzieren willst.
Also Python ist voll,
ist voll mit selfs.
Doch, doch, in Go gibt es auch sowas, klar
gibt es in Go. In Go
gibt es, heißt das nicht in Go
sogar auch self?
Da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, zumindest kannst du
es in Go nennen, wie du willst. Du kannst es, du kannst
die, die Klassenreferenz glaube ich
in Go auch, auch einfach
in der eigenen Variable irgendwie packen. Bin ich mal aus dem
Kopf nicht ganz sicher.
Aber sowas gibt es da auch, aber sowas muss
es ja im Endeffekt auch geben.
Gibt es nicht?
Doch, das gibt, warte mal.
Ja, das stimmt schon, es gibt
keine Klasse, self in Go.
Hier, in Go ist
name, Receiver Variable
heißt das Ding.
Receivers, Receiver
Variables. Boah, boah, meine Augen.
Ich seh nix.
Receiver, das da
meine ich, genau.
Also, auf sich selbst.
Ja, man kann es, man kann es letztendlich nennen
wie man will. Oder das hier?
Meine ich das?
Dafür mache ich zu wenig Go, da ich euch genau sagen kann
welches dieser Dinger ist.
Man kann es in Go
aber glaube ich nennen, wie man will.
So, okay.
Wo ist denn das Problem?
Das ist nicht das Problem.
Das, das ist nicht das Problem, ob
das jetzt self oder dis heißt.
Das Problem ist, dass man in Python so
oft, also zumindest das, was mir nicht gefällt,
man kann ja nicht mal sagen, also ich würde ja nicht mal
so weit gehen und sagen, das ist jetzt irgendwie ein großes
Problem. Das ist, das ist zwei Sachen.
Das ist Gewöhnungssache und
das ist persönliche, persönliche Präferenz.
Das ist ja eine Sache, die man aktuell eh nicht
haben darf, aber auf das Thema gehe ich
nicht ein.
Ja, also zumindest
mein Problem,
bei Python ist nicht, dass man
dis oder self verwendet, sondern
dass man zu oft self
verwenden muss.
Dass man an jeder Stelle
self benutzen muss.
Ja, der Typ hat vielleicht schon irgendwie
den Punkt zu sagen, ja das ist halt der Python
Style. Das ist schön und gut, aber ich find's trotzdem
nervig. Also du musst
Sekunde.
Wir haben den Kram doch vom letzten Mal glaube ich noch auf.
Ist bei dir schon Chat GPT
am Start? Ja, sogar in meiner VM.
Mehrfach.
Kram Start.
Guck mal, das mein ich. Das mein ich.
Also, wenn du, wenn du so
private Instanz
Variablen anlegen
willst, dann macht man das in Python
so. Man sagt self Punkt.
Ich find's übrigens schon persönlich ein bisschen doof,
dass man die Dinger hier nicht hier oben irgendwie definieren kann,
aber okay. Alles Geschmackssache.
So legst du die Dinger an.
Self Punkt. Underscore Underscore Text.
Es ist jetzt egal. Es geht nicht um den Underscore.
Du könnt's auch so machen, ja.
Alles okay.
Das Blöde, was ich finde, ist, dass du überall
zum überall drauf referenzieren
self brauchst. Guck.
Du brauchst self Punkt. Timer State.
Self Punkt.
Wenn du Duration aufrufen willst,
self Punkt Duration.
Das find ich
blöd. Also, bei Methoden
lass ich's mir irgendwie noch gefallen,
dass es expliziter ist,
auf was es sich bezieht.
Das mach ich in C Sharp übrigens auch persönlich
ganz gerne, dass ich bei
internen Methoden aufrufen sage
this.
Aber was ich überhaupt nicht mag, ist, dass man wirklich für
alles self braucht. Ich mein,
würde man sich da wirklich
zu viel einabbrechen, wenn man einfach
wenn man einfach so schreiben könnte,
anstatt self davor?
Gehört halt nicht in den Python Style,
aber muss mir ja nicht gefallen.
Genau. Das ist die genau gleiche Taktik,
ja. Kotlin ist das
Leute, früher oder
später,
früher oder später, wir müssen mal
ran.
Auch wenn MonkaS
ja war, angesagt ist.
Aber wir müssen mal ran.
Ja, genau.
So sieht's aus. Das ist das Problem.
Ach ja, zum Thema ChatGPT kann ich nur sagen,
ich hab einmal
ChatGPT
in der Kommandozeile.
Ich kann hier Sachen fragen, wie zum Beispiel
ChatGPT Omega 0, was nicht funktionieren wird,
weil garantiert meine Session Time Audit ist.
Also, ich hab einmal
einen ChatGPT Wrapper fürs
Terminal, da kann ich ChatGPT Sachen fragen,
wenn meine Session nicht ausgelaufen ist.
Aber ich war jetzt ein paar Tage mit der VM nicht bei,
bestimmt ist meine Session ausgelaufen.
Und ich habe GitHub
CodePilot bei
mir in der Shell. Den kann man dann
so was fragen, wie
How to Sync Files between Servers on Linux.
Und der
funktioniert in der Regel immer. Ja, guck, so macht man
das. Der Unterschied zwischen
beiden Sachen ist, also mal
abhängig davon, dass das
die Engine ist hinter GitHub CodePilot
und das da oben ChatGPT.
Der Unterschied ist auch,
der ChatGPT Wrapper ist kostenlos.
Der GitHub
CodePilot Wrapper
kostet Geld, weil du einen APK brauchst.
Das heißt, hierfür bezahle ich was
pro Abfrage. Aktuell, seriously,
bezahle ich nix, weil mein 18 Euro
Startguthaben, äh 18 Dollar Startguthaben hat
und es in der Beta
Phase ist, aber das kostet pro
API Request und mal gar nicht so
knapp. Wenn man Pech hat, kostet
es bis zu 2 Cent pro API
Call. Weil was man
ich versuch das mal zu erklären,
weil ich glaube, viele haben sich
die API Terms noch nicht
angeguckt von OpenAI
API
Pricing
Ah ja, die Seite ist sehr
schön. Excellent.
Excellent.
Was das?
OpenAI Pricing.
Was, was bin ich? Bin ich hier
irgendwas sehend, was man nicht sehen sollte,
oder?
Weiß ich ja nur. Hat man
jetzt da irgendwas gesehen, was ich nicht sehen sollte?
Was war denn
das? Na gut, ähm
Sah aus wie Base64, es war auch
Base64 encoded.
Das kann nicht mein API Key gewesen
sein, weil ich hier nicht eingeloggt bin.
Ja.
Also, ähm, wenn man sich
das Pricing, wenn man sich das Pricing
anguckt, vielleicht mach das grad nochmal, vielleicht ist
es dann wieder broken. Wenn man sich das
Pricing anguckt, was relevant ist, ist
hier zum Beispiel Language Models
DaVinci, oder
guckt euch die Language Models an.
Das ist das Interessante
hier, also du bezahlst zum Beispiel hier 2
Cent pro 1000
Tokens. Ein Token ist
so ungefähr,
ungefähr ein Wort, sagen wir mal.
Steht ja hier auch, glaube ich.
You can think of them as pieces of words.
Also,
sagen wir mal, so ungefähr ein Token ist
sagen wir mal, ein Wort ungefähr.
Die Sache ist nur die,
dass du nicht nur
deine Anfrage bezahlst.
Also mal angenommen, du möchtest hier
diesem, diesem Language Model eine
Anfrage stellen, so
warum
steigert Prime Subscription bei
Wooblors den IQ? Willst du die
fragen? Das ist nicht das
was du bezahlst. Du bezahlst
deine Anfrage, zumindest habe ich das
so verstanden. Du bezahlst
deine Anfrage plus den
Prompt. Und der Prompt ist das,
was dem Language Model sagt,
wie es sich verhalten
soll. Das heißt, der
Prompt ist quasi die Konfiguration
für das, für das Language Model.
Das heißt, du musst erstmal einen
Prompt hinschicken, um das
Language Model zu konfigurieren, dass es sich
so verhält, wie du möchtest.
Und da kannst du zum Beispiel
Prompt kannst du so einem Language Model
oder kannst du der AI beispielsweise
sagen, du bist,
du bist ein Linux Terminal
oder sowas in der Richtung.
Und dementsprechend
musst du den, musst du
das konfigurieren plus
deine Anfrage schicken. Und das heißt,
das ist deutlich mehr als deine Anfrage,
was du bezahlen musst. Da steht 750
Wörter pro 1000 Tokens. Ja, ich sag doch,
ungefähr, das ist so ungefähr
kannst du das in Wörtern rechnen.
Also kannst du ungefähr sagen so,
du brauchst einen Prompt plus deine
Anfrage und je nachdem wie der
Prompt geschrieben ist, die sind auch mal gerne ein bisschen länger,
dass man gescheite Antworten bekommt.
Dann bezahlst du so
ungefähr, tja, wenn du Pech hast
pro Anfrage ungefähr 2 Cent.
Also, dementsprechend
ist der Kram halt auch immer
verfügbar und sonst wie, aber kostet auch Geld.
Und ChatGPT selber,
ja, meine Session ist
ausgelaufen, ChatGPT
selber kostet nichts über den
Rapper. Ist beides ganz praktisch
und wisst ihr, wofür ich ChatGPT
tatsächlich, tatsächlich ganz gut finde?
Leute, ich log, ich muss euch mal
kurz ausblenden. Ich log mich mal kurz
ein
und dann zeige ich euch, wofür ich das
wofür ich das wirklich ganz, ganz nice finde.
Ich hoffe, ich weiß,
ChatGPT
ChatGPT is at capacity now.
Okay, wir können uns nicht einloggen.
Nope.
No pass. ChatGPT
ist ausgelastet gerade. Na gut.
Dann lassen wir's
bleiben. Also wie gesagt, wofür
ich ChatGPT wirklich mag, ist
sowas zum Beispiel, dass man,
ich hab's nicht mehr in der History drin,
dass man ChatGPT sowas fragen
kann wie
explain command
rsync-va
minus minus info
gleich
gleich progress.
Das finde ich nice.
Das ist manchmal
verkehrt,
aber zum größten Teil ist es
die Antwort gut und
ist oftmals schneller
und besser, als wenn man sich die Parameter
selbst über die Manpage
zusammensucht. Was natürlich noch besser
ist für Commandos, die unterstützt sind, ist,
wer das nicht kennt, ich zeig das mal,
explain shell ist
poggers. Explain.
Die Seite ist wirklich nice.
Die ist wirklich nice. Ja, hier kriegst
du, hier kriegst du auch, das ist quasi so
ein Wrapper für die Manpage, wenn du so willst.
Bloß, dass es dir das
die einzelnen Sachen erklärt. So.
Okay, es ist übrigens
gar nicht minus minus info,
info poggers.
Die Seite, die Seite ist auch wirklich, wirklich cool.
explain shell. Gibt bestimmt auch irgendeine
Konsolen
Plugin Integration.
Welches
Theme das ist für
ZSR?
Ups.
Das ist Starship,
allerdings
nicht
in der Default Config.
Und zwar meine Dot-Files gibt es noch nirgendwo,
weil ich übelst fauler Sack bin und nichts
hochlade. Aber ich euch schon
seit irgendwie gefühlt zwei Wochen versprochen hab,
dass ich was hochlade. Also der Prompt
ist das hier. Starship
und ich
bin einfach auf
Presets gegangen,
die irgendwo hier stehen.
Presets.
Und ich hab
dieses Preset genommen. M315
äh äh Pastel
Powerline basiert auf M315.
65 Princes.
Was ein Name.
Und das hab ich für mich
angepasst. Ich hab zum Beispiel
wie man hier sieht,
wie man hier sieht, ich hab die
die Farbe von
Weiß oder von diesem komischen
Grau, was das ist, umgestellt
auf meinen Shell Hintergrund.
Und ich hab noch ein paar andere Sachen hinzugefügt.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt in ein
.NET Projekt reingeht,
dann sieht man
also neben den Standardsachen, die drin sind, sieht man
jetzt auch äh
ausführlichere Git-Infos. Die sind
standardmäßig nämlich in dem Preset auch noch drin.
Und man sieht, welche
.NET Version aktuell bei mir
installiert ist. Und man sieht, welche
.NET Version, also global, systemweit
und welche .NET Version das jeweilige
Projekt als Target hat.
Hab ich noch zusätzlich eingestellt.
Und ich hab einen 2-Zeilen-Prompt draus
gemacht, anstatt einen 1-Zeilen-Prompt.
Weil, wie man hier schon
sieht, stellt euch mal vor, das wär ein 1-Zeiliger
Prompt. Dann wär mein Cursor jetzt
hier, dann würde ich jetzt quasi immer auf die
rechte Hälfte von meinem Bildschirm gucken
und hätte hier kaum Platz. Also hier
in der Zeile kann ich nichts Sinnvolles
mehr schreiben. Deswegen bin ich ein
Fan von 2-Zeilen-Prompt.
Ist ein bisschen Geschmackssache. Ich weiß nicht, wie es
bei euch ist, Chat, ob ihr eher
könnt ihr mal schreiben, ob ihr eher 2-Zeilige
oder 1-Zeilige Prompts mögt.
Aber ich
mag 2-Zeilige Prompts.
Gerade aus dem Grund, weil das immer an der
gleichen Stelle ist, wo man schreibt. Und
heutzutage ist der Bildschirm auch groß genug.
Muss man sich keine Gedanken machen.
Das heißt, ich hab die Standard
Vorlage hier genommen, wieder
und hab das angepasst zu
dem Zeug hier.
So sieht's aus.
Excellent.
Alter, ich freu mich schon auf meine neue
Heim-Server-Hardware. Eine dicke
übertrieben.
Ja, du hast extrem dicke übertrieben.
Die Sache ist nur die, du
brauchst wahrscheinlich die Leistung nicht, aber wenn man die
Kohle hat, ist doch alles nice.
Jetzt kommen bestimmt wieder Leute
und sagen, ja, aber der Stromverbrauch...
Nee, nee. Aktuelle
Hardware ist relativ gut, was Stromverbrauch
angeht. Also das Ding kann
übertrieben viel Strom fressen,
Leute. Ich sag euch, also, wenn er die Kiste
hier auf volle Leistung prügelt,
dann ist er bestimmt bei 5,
500, 600 Watt.
Allein schon
CPU und restliche Hardware.
Aber im Idle wird das Ding
trotzdem nicht bedeutend
über 20 verbrauchen. Also,
ich weiß ja nicht, wie viele
HDDs und SSDs da dran hängen. Aber wahrscheinlich
wird das Ding, je nachdem wie die
restliche Hardware ist, wahrscheinlich trotzdem nicht über 20, 30
Watt Idle verbrauchen. Eher 20.
Also insofern ist das
gar keine schlechte Wahl. Es ist
halt wahrscheinlich etwas übertrieben,
aber kann man machen. Warum nicht?
Verwendet ihr an der Arbeit ein Service-Match
wie ist... Nein, machen wir nicht.
Ich hab letztens dann...
Ich hab letztens danach geguckt,
was es ist. Ich hab's aber schon wieder vergessen.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Was ist denn das?
Ist IO?
Ist DIO?
Simplify Observable Traffic Management
Security and Policy with
Leading Service-Match.
Okay, ich hab den... Ich hab das jetzt gelesen.
Ich hab immer noch keine Ahnung, was es ist.
Was ist es denn?
What is IstIO?
Discover how Service-Match helps...
Ist das... Ist das im Prinzip
sowas wie Container-Orchestrierung?
So...
Also...
Also ernsthaft.
Anhand der Beschreibung kann ich mir jetzt
nicht so viel vorstellen.
Ist DIO addresses the challenging
developers and operators face
with the distributed
or microservice architecture?
Whether you're building from scratch
or migrating existing applications
to cloud native.
Ist DIO can help?
Ich hab seriously keine Ahnung, was es macht.
Discovery Configuration Certificates.
Es ist ein bisschen
Richtung Cloud Container-Orchestrierung.
oder sowas.
Keine Ahnung,
was es ist und ich kann
dir zumindest sagen, dass wir es nicht einsetzen.
Kann ich alles kennen.
Das Wichtige ist, wenn man jetzt feststellt,
es ist eine gute Lösung
für ein Problem, was man hat,
dass man sich das relativ schnell angucken kann.
Das ist ja das, worauf es in der IT
heutzutage ankommt. Nicht alles kennen,
aber sich, sag mal so gut genug
auskennen. Man kann durchaus seine
Spezialgebiete haben. Das ist ja letztendlich auch das,
wo man fette Stonks
Bezahlung kriegt. Aber
wichtig ist auch, dass man drum herum genug
kennt, dass man sich in neue Sachen schnell einarbeiten kann.
Und da hilft oftmals auch, sich in einem Gebiet
besonders tiefgreifend auszukennen.
Klingt jetzt doof,
weil man sagen würde, hey,
was bringt es mir, wenn ich mich in einem Gebiet
auskenne, mich ins andere einzuarbeiten.
Aber ich hab schon oft gemerkt, dass man viele Sachen
an Konzepten
und sonst wie trotzdem transferieren kann.
Auch wenn es unterschiedlich ist.
Auch wenn es unterschiedliche Themengebiete sind.
Und sei es nur die Art und Weise, wie man sich in etwas einarbeitet.
Also, neue Sachen lernen können,
möglichst schnell. Also, beste Google-Skills.
Das ist auch, was ich jedem Azubi immer
erzählt habe. Wir haben ja leider aktuell keine.
Das ist das Wichtigste, was
sie brauchen. Kannst ja mal das
Programm in C-Shot schauen, was weniger
Self hat. Das C-Shot-Programm hat easy weniger
Selfs, weil du kein Self
schreiben musst, um private Variablen
zuzugreifen.
Siehste, das ist was,
das interessiert mich persönlich überhaupt nicht.
Er schreibt, ich mag es an Python gar nicht,
dass die Klammern fehlen. Ich finde,
das macht den Code viel unübersichtlicher,
weil man schneller sieht, wie was zusammengehört.
Das stört mich zum Beispiel
überhaupt nicht. Ja, das finde ich
auch ein bisschen lächerlich.
Aber das stört mich beispielsweise überhaupt nicht.
Ich finde das vom Ansatz her mit den Einrückungen
gar nicht mal so doof.
Es hat ein paar Nachteile.
Doch Set Servers wollen wir uns auch anschauen.
Set Servers ist auf jeden Fall
auf Programm. Ich schreib mir das mal auf.
Gucken wir uns auf jeden Fall an.
Aber nicht heute. Heute bin ich zu sehr
im Arsch.
Es hat ein paar Nachteile.
Natürlich werden jetzt wahrscheinlich die Python-Kenner
wiederkommen und sagen, Max, das liegt gar nicht daran.
Gut, dann würde mich
aber die Begründung interessieren, woran es dann liegt.
Ich glaube, es gibt ein Problem,
was Python mit den Einrückungen hat,
die nicht mit den Einrückungen
jetzt wirklich selbst zusammenhängt,
sondern mit dem Parsing. Habt ihr euch zum Beispiel
schon mal gefragt, warum
es in Python nicht möglich ist, eine Multiline
Lambda Expression zu machen?
Also, warum es
in Python nicht möglich ist,
boah, Mann, Alter, meine Augen,
eine anonyme Funktion
als Parameter zu übergeben,
die länger als eine Zeile ist.
Das ist eine abartige
Syntax, finde ich. Allein schon,
dass man so ein Keyword
davor schreiben muss. Und es ist auch
maximal möglich, einzeilig
hier dahinter zu schreiben.
Also, was ich in .NET zum Beispiel machen kann,
ist sowas wie list.sort.
Ich weiß, das gibt es da nicht, aber sagen wir mal,
oder sagen wir mal, was weiß ich,
where, ja, oder
filter, nehmen wir das mal, filter,
f, blupf,
keine Ahnung,
bla bla bla blup, blup blup blup,
return, lulwe.
So, das kann ich in sich sharp machen.
Du musst das hinten dran machen für Multiline,
ja, Moment, Moment, wenn ich
einen Backslash hinten dran mache, dann ist es ja nicht wirklich
Multiline und
kann dann auch keine Sachen machen,
was eine zweite Zeile erfordert.
Es ist
eine einzelne Zeile
umgebrochen in mehrere Zeilen.
Das ist ja was anderes.
So, und in Python musst du sowas hier machen,
dann quasi list.filter,
äh, lambda, blupf,
ne, ne, warte mal,
x, x ist es so, glaube ich, ne,
blup, blabla, so, du kannst hier
keine Zeilen, du kannst hier nichts
Multiline-mäßig machen.
So, und ich gehe ganz stark
davon aus, das liegt daran,
weil sie Probleme haben,
den Parser für solche Ausdrücke zu
erweitern,
wann es anfängt und wann es
aufhört gescheit,
durch die Einrückung.
Das sage ich jetzt einfach mal,
ohne jemals am Python-Interpreter oder sonst
wie gearbeitet zu haben, das ist was,
was mir in meinem Bauchgefühl
sehr naheliegend erscheint.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es wirklich daran liegt,
aber
wenn nicht, würde mich interessieren, woran es dann liegt,
dass es nicht möglich ist.
Natürlich, die super
krassen Fanboys, die werden jetzt sagen,
ja, das liegt daran, weil
es nicht notwendig ist, für alles,
was länger ist als eine Zeile, kann man
doch einfach eine extra Funktion definieren.
Ja, man kann
sich das alles immer irgendwie schönreden, aber
es hat sicherlich seinen Grund, was sich die Language-Designer
dabei gedacht haben,
warum sie sowas naheliegendes
nicht machen.
Alternativen gibt es immer. Wie gesagt,
wenn wir alle perfekt wären und wenn die Welt
ganz toll wäre, dann würden wir alle mit Hexed-Edit
oder Fehlerfrei
binäre Programme
schreiben, die super krass und schnell und
fehlerfrei sind. Ist aber nicht so.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass es nur
einteilig möglich ist, liegt mit unter anderem daran,
weil sie Probleme haben, das in den Puzzle einzubauen,
wegen den
Einrückungen. Also ich habe
überhaupt keine Schmerzen mit den Einrückungen
an sich.
Die finde ich sogar ganz gut.
Das ist irgendwie auch das, was die Sprache mit auszeichnet.
Aber es gibt so ein paar andere Sachen,
die mir auf den Keks gehen.
Ja, ich weiß,
ich weiß, ich weiß.
Ja, demnächst müssen wir uns Kotlin
angucken, also Java.
Hackle.
Bing hat ChatGPT doch nun auch integriert.
Warte mal.
Total
Requests per month.
Alter, ist das
teuer, die Twitter-API.
Mal ganz davon
abgesehen, man kommt doch auch
als größerer, also mal angenommen,
man hat irgendeinen Service, der die Twitter-API
nutzt, mit 10.000
Tree-Quests
im Monat.
Das ist doch nichts.
10.000 Tree-Quests in der Stunde.
Ja, vielleicht, okay.
Aber doch nicht im Monat.
Und was wollen die dafür?
2.500
Das ist doch komplett lächerlich.
Stimmt das denn?
Ist das denn richtig, was die da
gepostet haben?
Twitter-API-Pricing.
Oh Mann, Alter, warum ist das?
Oh, Mensch.
So hell.
Okay, except.
Premium.
Tweets per Request. Ach, die man
fetchen kann?
Also, das ist unsinnig
teuer.
Das ist doch wirklich Unsinn.
Das ist doch wirklich Unsinn, das wird doch keiner
freiwillig benutzen.
Ja, super, damit haben sie auf einen Schlag
alle, aber komplett
alle Third-Party-Clients gekillt.
Also, Web-Services.
Was natürlich noch geht, sind Desktop-Clients
oder so, die sich ja mit User-Account
einloggen, das wird funktionieren.
Damit haben sie auf einen Schlag einfach mal
komplett das gesamte
Third-Party-Ökosystem
gekillt, was mit Sicherheits-
Absicht war.
Ja, habe ich beantwortet,
oder? Habe ich ja gesagt.
Custom-Config von diesem Standard-
Reset.
Jemand anderes wurde beleidigt?
Das ist auf Twitter ja normal, dass Leute beleidigt
werden. Ich meine, wart ihr die letzten
paar Tage, ups, sorry, falsch,
wart ihr die letzten paar Tage mal auf Twitter?
Ich glaube, ich habe noch nie.
Und ich bin schon lange auf Twitter, ja.
Ich habe noch selten einen
so großen,
wie kann man es nennen,
Circle-Jerk,
was auch immer, erlebt auf Twitter
wie die letzten Tage. Mann, Alter,
wie ging es da ab?
Da sind die Fetzen geflogen,
ey.
Wegen dem Wizard-Game.
Das war
echt absoluter Wahnsinn wieder auf Twitter, man.
Die Leute sind wieder komplett eskaliert.
Alle haben
ausflippen gewesen, man.
Das ist ja immer noch nicht vorbei, die flippen ja immer noch
aus.
Hast du schon mal Linux Mint genutzt? Wenn ja, was sagst du
dazu? Möchte auf der Arbeit auf
Linux wechseln und weiß nicht so ganz, welches
ich nehmen soll. Linux Mint ist super
Einsteiger-Distribution. Kann man sich nicht drüber
beschweren.
Kann ich dir wärmstens
ans Herz legen, Linux Mint zu verwenden.
Ich
muss sagen, mir persönlich
gefällt die Mate,
der Mate-Desktop von Mint am besten.
Das liegt aber auch daran, weil ich auf
minimalistische Desktops und
minimalistische Oberflächen stehe.
Oder minimalistischer. Deswegen
entweder ist bei mir XFCE-Mate oder irgendwie
Open oder Fluxbox oder sowas.
Oder halt das, was ich immer
benutze, E3. Aber Linux Mint
in Kombination mit einem der Desktops kannst du eigentlich kaum
was falsch machen. Letztendlich ist es
wobei, ist das überhaupt noch Ubuntu-based
oder ist es Debian-based mittlerweile?
Haben die nicht umgeschwenkt
auf Debian-based?
Das war mal Ubuntu. Haben die nicht
umgeschwenkt auf...
Mann!
Ich muss hier auch einen Darkreader installieren.
Ich...
sehe ja ab.
Debian and Ubuntu.
Oder wie die coolen Leute
sagen.
Verstehe.
Ja, kann ich dir empfehlen.
Ich würde allerdings vorher, aber das hast du ja wahrscheinlich schon,
ich sag's jetzt nur nochmal.
Ich würde vorher nochmal klären,
ob das in Ordnung
geht, dass du selbstständig
Linux auf deinem Arbeitsrechner installierst.
Weil vielleicht gehen ja manche Sachen
nicht, die sich die Firma vorstellt,
die gehen sollen.
Vielleicht benutzt ihr irgendwelche Windows-Desktop-Software,
irgendwelche vom Passwort-Save
bis zu sonstigen internen Dingern,
die nur unter Linux gehen.
Und ob die Firma damit einverstanden ist,
dass du damit deinen Rechner effektiv aus ihrem
AD und ihrer Verwaltung rausnimmst.
Wenn die damit kein Problem hat und das erlaubt,
kann ich dir Linux Mint
ans Herz legen. Ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
Okay, alles klar, jetzt ist es eh vorbei.
Ja, ist wirklich nice.
Macht Stats 1?
Ist das Summary?
Okay, da Marc schreibt, ich benutze es.
Bei mir auf der Arbeit
bin ich Preisangestellter, also es geht wahrscheinlich um Mint.
Hauptsächlich, weil das meiste an Anwendungen
bei uns goes, wird Ticketsystem,
Informationsportale und bin komplett auf Windows nicht angewiesen.
Bei PDF-Verarbeitung
auch mittlerweile im Browser möglich, brauche ich
auch den Adobe Stealth
nicht mehr. Ah, das ist gut.
Da hast du Glück.
Ich habe mittlerweile auf der Arbeit
es für mich so gelöst,
ich habe ein offizielles Windows-Notebook,
wo ich den ganzen
Corporate-Wahnsinn drauf machen kann,
den man da so braucht.
Und ein Linux-Notebook.
Ein Surface-Book. Das finde ich wirklich nice.
Das einzig dumme ist, das ist so
minimalistisch, dass du den Deckel nicht richtig aufkriegst.
Früher, stellt euch vor, es gab früher
bei Laptops am Deckel so einen kleinen
Schalter oder zumindest so eine kleine
Einbuchtung am Deckel, dass man den
Deckel einfacher aufmachen kann. Mittlerweile
sind die Dinger aber so krass
designt und stylisch und
lackglatt, dass es selbstverständlich
keine Einkerbung oder irgendwelche Sachen
gibt und du die Fingernägel brauchst,
um dein Notebook öffnen zu können.
Aber so ist das.
2023 geht Design eindeutig
über gute
Anwendungen.
Ansonsten ist das Surface-Book aber wirklich nice.
Habe das mit dem minimalistischen
Window-Management noch nie so richtig hinbekommen,
nutze ich jetzt einfach Gnome. Kannst du machen,
ich persönlich, ihr kennt mich, ihr wisst das,
ich benutze eigentlich so gut wie immer
i3, solange es
möglich ist, solange ich da selbst die Hoheit drüber
habe. i3 ist für mich die optimale
Kombination, weil ich mag nichts anderes
an Windows, äh an Linux.
Windows auch nicht, aber an
Linux-Desktops. Ich mag, also das
am ehesten, was noch am ehesten geht, ist wirklich
sowas wie, wie Mate oder XFCE
oder Open oder Fluxbox
oder sowas, wenn's
so ein richtig kompletter Desktop
mit Fenstern und
Geschiss sein muss. Ich mag
i3 und ich mag i3 aus dem
einzigen Grund, nicht weil es
irgendwie, weil ich unbedingt
Tiling-Window-Manager haben will oder sonst was,
wobei das schon ein bisschen
damit zusammenhängt. Ich mag
i3 aus dem einzigen Grund, weil
i3 einfach da ist, ohne irgendwie
im Weg zu sein. An i3
gibt's eigentlich kaum was, was
es überflüssig noch
darüber, guck mal, selbst diese Leiste
hier oben ist nicht von
i3. Es, das, das einzige
was von i3 ist,
ist tatsächlich die drei Desktop-Icons
hier oben und diese drei ähm
Workspace, Workspace-Icons oder
die bis zu neun möglichen
Workspace-Icons
und
ja, die ganze, diese ganzen
ähm Tastatur-Shortcuts
ja, wie Umschalten und sonst
wie was und ein bisschen, wenn ich's wirklich
haben will, Window-Management oder
Tiling-Management ist von i3.
Der Rest ist
andere Sachen, nicht i3.
Also i3 ist so schön minimalistisch,
deswegen mag ich gerne, benutze ich gerne
i3. Gibt, gibt noch mehr Alternativen
dazu. Muss, muss nicht i3
sein, aber i3 ist so, i3
ist quasi der Mainstream
Tiling-Window-Manager.
Woher ist denn die Leiste?
Das ist Bumblebee-Status.
Guck mal, wir können den
selbstprogrammierten Timer jetzt mal
auschecken hier. Gucken, ob der gleich
aus-out-timert.
Hallo zusammen, sagt der Gustl.
Oder ist es
Gust-i-Twitch?
Hallo zusammen, ich habe auf der Arbeit
ein kleines Problem. Wir haben eine
SQL-Tabelle.
Wenn mich einer triggern will, würde er jetzt sagen
eine SQL-Tabelle.
Kennt ihr die Leute, die nicht SQL
sagen, sondern Sequel?
Wobei ich da auch schon mehrere, mehrere
Aussprachen von gehört habe.
Wir haben eine SQL-Tabelle
mit 4 Terabyte
Daten. Das ist ganz schön viel.
Und es werden mehr. Darüber
gibt es einige Reports, deren Abfragen
manchmal 30 Minuten
benötigen. Total inakzeptabel.
Ja, das verstehe ich. Und da habe ich die Aufgabe,
diese Reports zu verbessern,
dass quasi instant ein Ergebnis
kommt. Ich dachte, die da in einem MongoDB
zu packen, was würdet ihr hier machen?
Okay, ich habe seriously keine Ahnung, was ihr mit eurer Datenbank
macht. Und ich bin auch kein
Datenbank-Optimierungsexperte.
Aber es gibt trotzdem ein paar Sachen, die mir einfallen.
Das erste ist, man kann Postgres irgendwie
partitionieren. Fragt mich nicht,
wie das genau funktioniert.
Das zweite ist,
kannst du die Dinger nicht im Voraus irgendwie
generieren? Also, dass du zum Beispiel
nicht jedes Mal alles zusammenrechnen
musst, sondern schon
während die Daten erstellt
werden, anfängst zusammenzurechnen.
Nee, nicht Cache.
Nee, nee, nee, das meine ich nicht.
Also, du könntest doch zum Beispiel...
Ich habe ja keine Ahnung, wie das
jetzt aussieht.
Aber sagen wir mal, es werden
alle User-Requests gelockt.
Was wahrscheinlich DSGVO
TOS ist, aber gehen wir mal raus.
Es werden User-Requests gelockt und du möchtest
quasi wissen,
in einem Report,
wie viele User-Requests
es gegeben hat
im Monat. Du könntest ja
ein extra Feld
anlegen. Wie nennt man das in der Tabelle?
Extra Feld?
Keine Ahnung. Du könntest ja
ein extra Feld anlegen oder irgendwie
so eine Summary-Tabelle machen,
wo du
beispielsweise einmal hochzählst
pro User-Request. Also sprich,
dass das dann nur noch aus
dieser Tabelle abgefragt werden
muss für den
Report und nicht für den Report
jedes Mal frisch zusammen
gerechnet werden muss.
Kann ChatGPT nicht fragen, weil meine Session
timeoutet ist und ich mich gerade nicht einloggen
kann, weil
es überlastet ist.
So, soviel als jemand, der keine Ahnung
von DSGVO. Solche Sachen sind
genau richtig bei mir auf Twitch.
Ich hab dazwischen keine Ahnung, aber ich weiß, dass wir
im Chat einige Leute haben, die Ahnung haben
und deswegen,
das passt hier schon richtig
gut hin. Aber mehr kann ich dir
dazu auch nicht sagen,
weil ich da datenbanktechnisch
jetzt nicht so den Wahnsinn... Also, noch mal
ein zweites Datenbanksystem dazu
zu packen, halte ich jetzt erstmal für
nicht so sinnvoll.
Das würde ich
vermeiden. Ich weiß nicht,
ob dir ein Index wirklich was
bringt an der Stelle.
Ein Index ist
ja gut, wenn
du... Also, Leute, Datenbank
und ich, ihr wisst, dass das nicht
mein Fachgebiet ist.
Ein Index ist ja in der Regel, denke ich, nur
gut, wenn du
schnell auf eine
wie heißt das? Eine Row?
Wie heißt das bei Datenbank?
Also, wenn du schnell auf Einträge zugreifen willst,
über was anderes als den
Primary Key. Aber wenn du
trotzdem wissen willst,
wie viele Anfragen gab es im letzten
Monat, dann musst du
die Dinger ja alle rausziehen
und zählen. Es sei denn,
du hast im Vorfeld schon irgendwie zusammengefasst.
Beispielsweise bei jedem
Request. Jetzt kommt das Sarix
und sagt ChatGPT ist sehr gut.
Ich glaube, das sind so
Sachen, wo dir ChatGPT auch nur so allgemeines
Zeug erzählt. Ach so,
na dann ist ja gut. Das machen wir
übrigens immer noch nicht.
Selbstverständlich werden die OpenAI verkaufen.
Die verkaufen OpenAI ja schon.
Du kannst ja jetzt schon API
Pricing und alles
einsehen. Und du kannst es, glaube ich, jetzt auch schon
kaufen. Die werden das verkaufen. Die werden das
genauso verkaufen, wie GitHub
CodePilot, was ja übrigens auch OpenAI ist.
Die ist garantiert.
Selbstverständlich.
Gibt es ja seit ein paar Tagen
schon Premium.
PleaseSmile. Dankeschön für den PrimeSub.
Sorry, Leute, falls ich irgendjemanden vergessen habe.
Hypersubscription hier.
Du hast noch gar nichts verpasst.
Neusterschreis
Squal
für SQL. Das wird ja immer schlimmer.
Das wird ja
immer schlimmer, Mann.
Panda2. Dankeschön für den Sub.
CloudNativeMenschen würden wahrscheinlich
viel sagen, wenn er taglang ist.
Also allein schon,
dass der überhaupt noch eine self-hosted Datenbank
hat, geht ja gar nicht.
Das Ganze, das Ganze
muss zumindest in irgendeinen
Cloud-Service.
Und dann drüber zugegriffen
wird dann auch nur über
irgendwelche, wie heißt
das bei Microsoft? WebApp
Functions? Ne,
WebApps. Und
die Reports, selbstverständlich,
nur über Azure Functions
generiert.
Was
eventuell vielleicht auch noch in Ordnung
geht, ist, wenn du einen Managed Kubernetes Cluster
bei Azure kaufst, um dort eine Anwendung
noch draufzudeployen.
Aber ich glaube, das ist immer noch nicht
immer noch nicht Buzzword genug für richtig
krasse CloudNativeMenschen.
gRPC-Abfragen. Ne, das ist
auch nicht CloudNative genug.
CloudNative wer?
Keine Ahnung.
Bin ich
anscheinend nicht CloudNative genug für.
Gibt's schon Blockchain-Datenbank?
Klar.
AlbinoGuy, danke schön für den Sub.
Na, er wird jetzt grundsätzlich
seinen Datenbankaufbau ja nicht mehr
ähm, inkompatibel ändern
können, oder? Weil ich mein,
sie haben vier Terabyte an Daten
da drinnen. Da schmeißt
er nicht mal kurz alles über den Haufen.
Ich mein, eine Sache,
seriously, eine Sache, die mir
einfällt, die unabhängig von
einer Datenbank geht, die aber wahrscheinlich
auch nicht die sinnvollste Lösung ist.
Also eine Sache, die mir aus Entwicklersicht
einfällt, die man machen könnte, ist,
du kannst einfach faken.
Du weißt ja wahrscheinlich, wann
das Reports, also wie die Reports
aussehen, oder was in die Reports rein
muss. Du lässt die Reports einfach
einmal pro Nacht generieren,
und wenn eine Anfrage kommt,
lieferst du den letzten
pre-rendered Report
quasi aus. Dann ist auch scheißegal, ob das
eine halbe Stunde dauert, weil nachts um, um drei
Uhr fünfundsiebzig, nee,
drei Uhr fünfundsiebzig,
ob drei Uhr fünfundsiebzig generiert,
interessiert das keinen mehr.
Dann juckt's nicht. Und dann kann dann
irgendjemand aus dem Vorstand
kommen und seinen krassen Report generieren.
Und das geht
innerhalb von zwei Sekunden, weil der Report schon
pre-generated ist.
Ja, genau sowas in der Richtung hab ich mir auch grad überlegt.
Okay, jetzt kommen die ganzen
High-IQ-Datenbank-Leute.
Kommt mal ein Video zu OpenAI
ChatGPT.
Ähm,
ich weiß nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll
großartig, weil
ChatGPT YouTube ist voll
damit. Es hat jeder schon
was zugesagt. Es wurde mehr oder
weniger alles dazu gesagt.
Es ist jetzt nicht so,
dass ich ein wahnsinnig großer
OpenAI-User bin.
Klar, ich hab das auch schon ausprobiert. Wir haben's
hier im Stream schon ab und zu gemacht. Ich benutze
GitHub CodePilot. Ich hab auch schon im Stream
Sachen abgefragt, aber
ich weiß nicht, was ich großartig dazu
erzählen soll.
Ich mein, dass es Entwickler überflüssig machen
wird, halt ich für
Blödsinn. Genauso wie, dass
uns Low-Code-Tools, dass
Low-Code-Tools demnächst dann die Manager
alles programmieren und du keinen Entwickler mehr
brauchst. Das glaub ich alles nicht.
Ich geh davon aus, dass
Technologien
wie ChatGPT
in Zukunft auch im Alltag
vermehrt eine Rolle spielen
werden. Zumal sie heute schon
sehr hilfreich sein können.
Ich sag nur YouTube Clickbait
Titelgenerator oder solche
Geschichten. Oder solche Tools
wie
keine Ahnung, Jim
schreibt dir eine Mail und
du hast grad keinen Bock auf den
und du sagst dann irgendeiner AI
Alter, AI
sagt Jim, er soll die Fresse halten, aber das auf
net und
copy-pastes das dann in die E-Mail. Also
es gibt schon
paar ganz coole und sinnvolle
Anwendungen. Man merkt aber, dass vieles
noch ziemlich in der Findungsphase
ist. Also es gibt ja zum Beispiel Tools wie
Home-App
oder so.
Also das ist jetzt das erste was mir
einfällt. Das ist ein Service, damit kannst
du quasi Präsentationen generieren
aus
einem Thema. Wobei man halt
wirklich sagen muss, das was da an Präsentationen
rauskommt, das sieht hier auf dieser
Preview, auf dieser Vorstellungsseite
viel cooler aus, als es in
Wirklichkeit ist.
Also dem Ding gibst du einen Titel
und
dann generiert es dir einen Text
für deine Slides
und
generiert auch Bilder
dafür.
Das was da rauskommt,
da drüber kannst du aber ehrlich gesagt
damit kannst du keine Präsentation halten.
Du kannst auch ganz auf
Rewrite drücken und sowas.
Es mag vielleicht
sinnvoll sein als
Ergänzung und das ist das, wo ich
in Zukunft auch das meiste noch
der ganzen AI-Geschichten sehe.
Zumindest das, was man so im täglichen
Arbeitsablauf
oder so im täglichen Benutzen
im Einsatz hat, als Unterstützung.
Wo ich mir das zum Beispiel durchaus
vorstellen kann, sowas als Art
Powerpoint-Plugin zu haben, wenn dir
gerade nichts selbst einfällt. Du weißt,
okay, so eine Viertelstunde
Präsentation, du weißt
vielleicht auch ungefähr was du sagen willst, aber du hast jetzt
gerade keine gute Idee,
wie du dieses, dieses,
dieses eine Sub-Thema
irgendwie in deine Präsentation packen willst.
Du fragst mal die AI und hast
dann vielleicht dadurch ein bisschen Inspiration,
was du machen könntest. Das ist alles sinnvoll,
dass es
Programmierer überflüssig machen
wird, dass es
Grafik-Designer überflüssig
machen wird oder dass es
Illustrator-Leute
überflüssig machen wird
oder Grafik-Designer und sowas.
Blödsinn, das wird erstmal nicht passieren.
Naja, also ich kenne jemanden,
ich kenne jemanden,
ich habe vor kurzem,
vor zwei Tagen
oder drei Tagen, habe ich mit einem
zusammen ein bisschen,
es hat sich so ergeben,
wir haben ein bisschen Bewerbung
für ihn zusammengeschrieben im Discord
und da haben wir tatsächlich
AI verwendet
dabei.
Hauptsächlich DeepL, um die Sache
zu übersetzen.
Beziehungsweise um ein bisschen Inspiration
für die Übersetzung zu holen, weil die Bewerbung gab es
in Deutsch und in Englisch.
Und bei manchen Sachen haben wir uns gefragt,
hä, das wird doch so nie
jemand auf Englisch schreiben.
Oder umgedreht, manchmal haben wir die Sachen auf Deutsch übersetzt
und haben gesagt, das wird doch so niemand auf Deutsch
schreiben. Für solche Sachen,
für sowas ist das wirklich nice.
Aber ich glaube, es muss keiner wirklich Angst
um seinen Job haben, dass demnächst
AI das übernehmen wird.
Also im kreativen Bereich.
Und Access, also
wer irgendwelche Produktivsysteme
auf Access-Basis betreibt, der hat eh glaube ich
eine Kontrolle über sein Leben verloren.
Weil ich das wahrscheinlich nicht sagen sollte, weil
es viel mehr produktiv eingesetzte
Access-Systeme gibt, als man für möglich hält.
Kann man gleich gucken.
Hier ist eine Playlist für die Musik,
ja.
Top 50 Mario Songs of all time.
Von Enrico.
Top Lists.
Es gibt bestimmt Blockchain-Datenbanken.
Ja doch, dann könnten wir
das doch noch mit gRPC machen.
Und was ist, was ist mit
GraphQL, was sagt da die Cloud
Native Computing Foundation dazu?
Was sagen die?
Was sagen die zu GraphQL?
Kann man da irgendwie suchen zu?
Nix.
Ach gut, das ist kein
Projekt von denen. Dann verstehe ich.
GraphQL ist ja auch kein
Implement...
Hier haben die Implementierung und nicht...
Wobei, warum ist da gRPC da?
Ah, kein Schimmer.
Geh oben auf Landscape.
Projects.
Wo?
Lands...
Ah ja, Cloud...
Cloud Native
Monks. Man, das ist ne geile
Seite, die muss ich mir speichern.
gRPC.
Okay, da kann man da drinnen
suchen.
Wie sucht man da drinnen? Da hat wahrscheinlich
bei den Cloud Native Leuten keiner dran gedacht,
dass man auch die Seite durchsuchen möchte.
Kann man da suchen.
Card Mode.
gRPC.
Äh, ich finde es nicht.
Wo ist es?
Hier, gRPC.
Alles klar.
Die sagen, gRPC
Incubating.
Alles klar.
GraphQL?
Auf der Seite siehst du doch nix.
Ah ne, es gibt nur eine GraphQL
Engine. Alles klar.
Was denn die alles gibt?
Hm. Oh ja, unsere
unterwegs Datenbank früher war auch riesengroß.
Die haben sie dann irgendwie
partitioniert auf mehrere Kisten.
Ich weiß nicht, wie sie es genau gemacht haben.
Bei uns auf der Arbeit?
Oracle.
Aber ich bin bei ner Bank, wir haben das Geld.
Macht euch da keine Gedanken.
Die werden nicht pleite gehen.
Aber das Zeug ist der Teufel,
Leute.
Wir haben ChatGPT letztens gefragt,
was er für
Clickbait Video Thumbnail Vorschläge
hat. Jetzt in Google
Microsoft investieren.
Keine Ahnung, musst du dir selbst überlegen.
Ich bleib weiter bei meinen
ETF Stonks.
Was macht da eigentlich mein
mein Stonk
Stonks grade?
Nicht wirklich
viel.
Blubblubblubblubblub.
Nein, wir haben HAproxy. HAproxy ist wirklich
gut, da kann man nix gegen sagen. Also HAproxy
haben wir auch teilweise im Einsatz.
HAproxy flutscht, HAproxy ist
gute Software. Aha.
Der One Finger Man weiß Bescheid.
Hattet ihr mal einen
blöden Chef? Oh ja, hatte ich.
Mehrfach, mehrfach.
Die letzten zwei sind allerdings
dafür gut gewesen.
Davor hatte ich eigentlich fast nur blöde Chefs.
Ich hatte beim Provider nen
blöden Chef, hatte bei der Bank
wo ich jetzt arbeite nen blöden Chef
am Anfang.
Der nächste war auch
blöde, der danach war auch blöde.
Die letzten zwei, die sind ganz gut gewesen.
Also der
vorletzte, der davor gewesen und
der aktuelle ist immer noch.
Ich überlege gerade die Abteilung zu wechseln, weil ich
mit dem Chef nicht klarkomme.
Gestern beispielsweise wurde mir vorgeworfen,
ich würde ihn und einen Kollegen
in einer Remote Arbeitsgruppe
veräppeln und nicht wertschätzen.
Boah, die haben immer Probleme, Mann.
Weil ich mit den anderen Kollegen vor Ort zum Mittagessen
gegangen bin, mich knapp ver...
Ja, wo ist das Problem, wenn das
Meeting fertig war? Was hat der denn
für Schmerzen? Also...
Das ist ne doofe Situation, weil es ist ein Chef.
Also...
ultimativen Ratschlag
kann ich dir da nicht geben zu...
Aber...
Also eins kann ich dir...
Für ihn war das Meeting nicht zu Ende.
Naja gut, wenn ein Meeting nicht zu Ende ist, dann einfach
rauszugehen in die Pause
ist tatsächlich nicht
die feine englische Art. Ich meine, ich kenn jetzt natürlich
die...
den genauen
Ablauf nicht.
Aber normalerweise merkt man doch, wenn ein Meeting
fertig ist.
Also meistens, wenn alle Tschüss sagen, ist ein Meeting fertig.
Und wenn das der Fall war?
Also wenn es für alle
so aussah, als ist das Meeting
fertig, nur für ihn nicht,
dann soll er an seiner Auffassungsgabe
ein bisschen arbeiten.
Also...
Also es ist tatsächlich schwierig,
wenn du persönliche Probleme mit deinem
Chef hast, beziehungsweise ihr...
Es gibt Leute, es gibt Leute, die können,
das muss man ja auch mal sagen, es gibt Leute, die kommen einfach
miteinander nicht klar. Da kann man noch
nicht so professionell sein.
Es gibt Leute, die reden immer aneinander vorbei
und es gibt Leute, die kommen von ihrer Art einfach
nicht miteinander klar.
Und die können sich auch nur bis zu einem gewissen Punkt
zusammenreißen. Also das ist ja durchaus möglich.
Ansonsten ist das
wahrscheinlich das einfachste, was
du machen kannst, sachlich zu bleiben und sagen,
es haben sich alle verabschiedet,
woher sollst du denn wissen?
Also was hätte er denn
anders erwartet, ja?
Weil wenn alle Tschüss sagen, dann scheint
das Meeting wohl zu Ende zu sein.
Und außerdem,
ähm,
das einfachste, um solche Probleme zu vermeiden,
also wenn es ihn wirklich, wenn es
ihn wirklich stört und das Probleme
sind, die häufiger
vorkommen, das einfachste,
um solche Probleme zu vermeiden, ist tatsächlich
mal das zu
machen, was man, wofür man als Chef
da ist in dieser Situation.
Mit den Leuten reden und zwar,
indem man sagt, okay, wir müssen halt so ein
paar grundsätzliche, ähm,
ja, ein paar grundsätzliche
Regeln aufstellen, was Meetings angeht.
So nach dem Motto, solange noch Leute
reden über das eingeladene
Thema, ist das Meeting nicht vorbei und das
Meeting ist erst vorbei, wenn, keine Ahnung,
der Protokollschreiber alles
aufge... Keine Ahnung, irgendwie sowas, wenn's
da wirklich, wenn's da wirklich Probleme gibt.
Aber ansonsten,
wenn es einfach ein Depp ist,
ist es natürlich schwierig.
Es gibt unglaublich viele Vorgesetzte,
die sich...
die sich überhaupt nicht dafür eignen.
Wo du das Gefühl hast,
die sind da, weil sonstigen zwei untergekommen sind.
Also gibt's
genug unfähige Leute.
Aber er muss halt einfach mal sagen,
was er denn anders hätte
erwartet und bzw. wenn die Leute
alle Tschüss sagen und gehen weg, ja,
ja, die gibt's.
Aber die Stunde wird bezahlt.
Das muss man sich dann immer
vor Augen führen.
Also, das ist
eine Sache, wo ich festgestellt habe,
also so,
wie soll ich sagen, so,
auf gewollt,
so gewollt
auf Alphatier machen,
ist meistens nicht
die richtige Variante,
um
dass Sachen nicht eskalieren, ja.
Also wenn man,
wenn man quasi dann sagt,
ich lass mir hier gar nix
sagen und sonst was,
das führt meistens nicht dazu, dass
die Situation entspannter
wird auf Dauer.
Nee, will ich nicht.
Es war kein wichtiges Meeting, es war eine
Arbeitsgruppe in den
Fortbildungstagen.
Gut, da weiß ich nicht, wie's da bei euch mit Anwesenheit aussieht,
also wenn ich ne Schulung habe,
da sollte man schon warten, bis
dort Pause ist, bevor man abhaut.
Also man kann sich ja auch immer
überlegen, das ist übrigens ne Sache, die ich
an sich nicht verkehrt finde,
man kann sich ja
durchaus auch mal überlegen, okay,
vielleicht
ist das
aus diesen und diesen Gründen verkehrt angekommen,
was ich gemacht hab.
Also man kann ja durchaus
auch mal ein bisschen gucken bei sich,
vielleicht hätte man Sachen anders machen sollen,
dass es nicht irgendwie zu Missverständnissen
kommt oder vielleicht hat man sich ja auch,
wenn man mal wirklich drüber nachdenkt
und auch mal sich in die Situation vom
Chef reinversetzt, vielleicht war's auch wirklich
keine gute Idee und man lässt's in Zukunft,
ich kann's jetzt wirklich nicht
sagen, weil ich nicht einschätzen
kann, was da
jetzt genau ist.
Also dafür laber ich relativ viel Privates
mit den Leuten auf der Arbeit.
Ja das ist, das ist immer Geschwätze, wir sind
eine Familie, bla bla bla.
Gerade Gehaltserhöhung
abgelehnt bekommen, aber mitbekommen,
dass alle neuen Leute auf das,
auf demselben Entwicklungslevel
zwischen, dann guck dich einfach mal um,
was es sonst noch so gibt. IT-Jobs,
IT-Leute werden überall gesucht,
und dann wirst du sehen, wie schnell die sich,
wie schnell die sich rühren.
Sofern, und diese
Option besteht ja immer,
gerade wenn man sich dann auch mal umguckt,
die Option besteht ja immer, dass
man vielleicht, ich will nicht
sagen, dass es bei dir so ist, ich sag nur,
dass es eine Möglichkeit ist,
dass man sich selbst als toller einschätzt,
als man ist. Das kommt ja
manchmal vor.
Aber wenn du sagst, dass Leute auf
ähnlichem Level wie dir und
dann ist das natürlich fragwürdig.
Aber wie gesagt,
guck dich um, guck dich um,
und du wirst sehen, wie schnell die hüpfen,
wenn sie das mitbekommen, wenn du wirklich gute Arbeit machst.
Und du wirst auch
dich vor Angeboten aktuell kaum retten können.
Das Gute ist,
was wirklich eines der wenigen
guten Sachen, was Corona uns gebracht hat,
ist, dass Homeoffice mittlerweile viel
etablierter ist, und dass
auch viele Unternehmen halt deutschlandweit
suchen und auch sagen, 100% Remote.
Sparst du oder investierst du?
Ich kaufe ETFs. Nicht alles.
Also, das meiste
liegt tatsächlich sinnlos rum.
Ja, mal abwarten.
In unserem Unternehmen gibt es sowas wie Tage,
wo man aus den Projekten rausgezogen wird und
die Tage für andere Themen investieren kann.
Da können Schulungen stattfinden oder lockere Arbeitsgruppen,
wo man Internet-Tools... Also, wenn das eine lockere
Arbeitsgruppe ist,
wo quasi klar ist,
jeder kommt und geht
zur Mittagspause, wenn es gerade
passt, dann sehe ich da überhaupt
kein Problem drin. Vielleicht
weiß das der Chef
bloß nicht, weil er noch nie
sowas mitgemacht hat.
Dann würde ich ihn einfach fragen, was
er denn erwartet, weil die Regeln sind dann relativ
klar.
Oder warum er das anders
einschätzt, kann man ihn ja mal fragen.
Es scheint ja
etabliertes Vorgehen zu sein,
dass die Leute
in diesen
quasi, wie heißt das nochmal, in so lockeren
Arbeitsgruppen Mittagessen gehen,
wenn es gerade passt.
Also, warum er denn eine andere Ansicht ist.
Wie er da drauf kommt, kann man ihn
durchaus mal fragen.
Selbst der Chef war stundenlang... Ja, dann erst
recht. Da würde ich ihn erst recht mal fragen,
was denn jetzt eigentlich genau...
Also, wie er sich das denn vorgestellt hat, auf welcher
Grundlage. Also, wie er da drauf kommt.
Mein Unternehmen bildet
absolut miserabel aus. Hast du einen Tipp, wie man
damit umgehen sollte? Ja.
Selbst was lernen. Scheiß drauf,
was die machen. Du wirst sie nicht
verbessern können. Du kannst natürlich...
Kenne den Laden nicht. Du kannst natürlich sagen,
hier, guck mal, ich würde mir wünschen, dass
ich mal einer hinsetze.
Du kannst natürlich durchaus,
selbst wenn ihr mal einen Ausbildungsvertreter
bei euch habt und sowas, der
dein Hauptansprechpartner für sowas
ist, kannst du natürlich mal sagen,
dass du dir mehr in diese Richtung
wünschen würdest. Aber, ganz ehrlich,
so wie du das sagst, sieht es
für mich eher so aus, als sind die nicht in der Lage,
dich ordentlich auszubilden. Das liegt
wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal daran, weil sie es nicht wissen.
Sie können es wahrscheinlich einfach nicht besser.
Das einzige, was du machen kannst, ist scheiße
drauf. Du wirst sie wahrscheinlich nicht ändern können.
Das einzige, was du machen kannst, ist selbst
lernen, was dich interessiert
und selbst besser werden in deinen
bevorzugten Gebieten, so dass
du später viel Know-How in den Bereichen
hast und dementsprechend auch deutlich bessere Chancen
hast, in den Bereichen
arbeiten zu können, auf die du Bock hast. Das einzige,
was du machen kannst, ist selbst lernen.
Was übrigens in der IT
eigentlich immer so ist.
Also man kann sich
nie drauf verlassen,
dass man
alles, dass man die Sachen
irgendwie großartig beigebracht bekommt.
Wir haben auch so ein paar Kandidaten bei uns,
das verstehe ich auch immer nicht. Wenn es
was Neues gibt, sagen die pauschal
ach, schreibt mal
in Chat, ob ihr auch so Leute kennt, ja?
Schreibt mir das mal in Chat, das würde mich echt interessieren.
Aber wir haben bei uns so Leute, es gibt was Neues
und das erste, was du von den Leuten hörst,
ach, das ist ja schon
wieder was Neues. Ach, davon habe
ich erstmal, davon habe ich keine Ahnung.
Die sollen mir erstmal eine Schulung bezahlen.
Dann arbeite ich auch damit.
Kennt ihr so Leute?
Das triggert mich immer richtig.
Wo ich mir denke so, meine Güte, es geht hier doch
jetzt nicht irgendwie, wir bauen doch jetzt nicht irgendwie
eine Rakete, die irgendwie zum Mond fliegen muss oder so.
Das sind halt neue Tools oder
neue Services.
Die muss man sich halt mal angucken
und wenn man die sich angeguckt hat, ein paar Tage
verwendet, da kommt man da schon rein.
Jetzt stellt euch mal nicht so an, Alter.
Was macht dich happy?
Prime-Subs.
.
. .
Und in der IT arbeiten
Ihr solltet das Gegenteil von Schiss haben
Ihr solltet sagen, mir gefällt was nicht
Mach besser oder ich hau ab
Um es jetzt mal übertrieben zu sagen
Ihr müsst euch wirklich keine Gedanken machen
Die rennen euch die Bude ein
Und wenn ihr es nicht glaubt
Wenn ihr es nicht glaubt
Auch wenn das nicht die besten Angebote sind
Aber wenn ihr es nicht glaubt
Macht euch einen LinkedIn Account
Und schreibt einfach mal die Sachen rein
So an Skills
Und ein bisschen im Business Speak
Ihr bekommt
Was weiß ich, 10 Anfragen am Tag
Wenn das mal reicht, je nachdem was es ist
Das ist natürlich nicht unbedingt gut
Alles was da an Anfragen kommt
Das meiste ist Schrott
Aber nur das ihr seht, ihr kriegt massig
Massig Anfragen
Und selbst wenn ihr euch irgendwo
Bewerbt
Die sind sehr, also zumindest was ich
Was ich jetzt mitbekomme, ich hab mich jetzt ja auch baum
Die sind da mittlerweile echt
Sehr flexibel und entgegenkommend
Zum Beispiel
Wir nehmen mal den Job
Auf den ich mich jetzt beworben hab
Wo es jetzt auch geklappt hat
Und wo ich jetzt, also bei der Versicherung in Frankfurt
Da wo ich jetzt auch am 1.
Anfangen werde
Das ist, die sind nicht unbekannt
Also das ist
Schon ein Unternehmen, was die Leute kennen
Ja ich sage euch den Namen nicht, aber das kennt man
Und
Selbst dort
Hat sich
Oder haben sich
Nur ganz wenige auf diese Stelle beworben
Also ich kann es euch jetzt
Ich weiß es ja auch nur vom Erzählen
Also im Prinzip keine Ahnung
Wie viel es jetzt wirklich waren
Aber ich wüsste nicht warum die Mist erzählen sollen
Ich weiß, dass ich auf meine Stelle
Genau einer beworben hat
Außer mir
Einer
Und das war intern
Und dort ist es dann irgendwie nicht
Zurstande gekommen
Weil er irgendwie doch keinen Bock mehr hatte oder so
Keine Ahnung
Es hat sich einer beworben
Und das war eigentlich jemand, der den Vorzug hätte
Bevor ich diese Stelle überhaupt hätte bekommen können
Einer
Und das ist eine bekannte
Das ist eine bekannte Versicherung
Das ist ein großes Frankfurter Unternehmen
Die Stellenanzeige war jetzt
Nichts herausragendes, aber jetzt auch nicht super schlecht
Und sie bezahlen
Wirklich gut
Und das hat sich einer
Und das war intern irgendwie beworben
Also ihr müsst euch wirklich keine Gedanken machen
Ihr müsst das Gegenteil von Schiss haben
Den Job zu verlieren
Ihr könnt davon ausgehen
Niemand, der noch bei Sinnen ist
Und der nicht Google oder Microsoft ist
Und schlicht und ergreifend einfach viel zu viele Leute
In den letzten Jahren übereingestellt hat
Und festgestellt hat, hups, wollen wir gar nicht
Schmeißt aktuell IT-Leute freiwillig raus
Und wenn sie es machen
Kann ja durchaus sein, irgendwelche Umstrukturierungsmaßnahmen
Findet ihr wahrscheinlich um die nächste Ecke
Was besseres
Also ich
Wie gesagt
Ich würde erstmal nicht so viel drauf geben
Was dir jemand erzählt
So nach dem Motto
Du bist unterbezahlt
Sonst wie
Da wird viel Mist erzählt
Das einzige wie du das feststellen kannst
Ist wirklich mal dich ein bisschen umhören
Du kannst dir Stellen raussuchen bei dir in der Nähe
Du kannst dir wirklich die besten Sachen raussuchen
Was dich am größten anspricht
Ja, du musst dir nicht irgendeinen Mist nehmen
Such dir wirklich ein paar gute Sachen raus
Wo du sagen würdest
Hey, das gefällt mir
Da hätte ich Bock drauf
Vielleicht gefällt es dir auch wirklich so gut
Dass du dann am Ende hingehst
Du kannst entweder dort anrufen
Wenn du Fragen hast
Du kannst natürlich dich auch gleich bewerben
Oder einfach mal checken
Was so abgeht
Ich meine, es zwingt dich ja keiner
Den Kram anzunehmen
Und dann sagst du im Zweifelsfall
Hier Chef
Ich hab mich
Ich hab einen anderen Vertrag auf dem Tisch liegen
Wenn du das vorher nicht öffentlich machen willst
Ist ja sinnvoll
Gibt ja durchaus Unternehmen
Da kriegst du vielleicht Probleme
Wenn du es im Vorfeld erzählst
Also ich hab es meinem Chef
Beispielsweise schon seit ein paar Monaten
Vorher erzählt
Dass ich mich am Bewerben bin
Und auch vielversprechende Sachen habe
Und jetzt bin ich da
Auch einen Vertrag auf dem Tisch liegen habe
Dann ein bisschen später
Aber gut, muss sich jeder überlegen
Wie er das macht
Ich würde es nicht empfehlen
Das vorher zu erzählen
Ich würde eher die Klappe halten
Du kannst vielleicht
Wenn du wirklich gute Kollegen hast
Und dich mit denen ein bisschen abstimmen willst
So hier
Hast du mal gehört
Wie findest du meine Werbung
Kann man machen
Wenn du denkst
Die halten die Klappe
Das ist kein Ding
Aber großartig
An die große Glocke hängen würde ich es nicht
Und wenn du dann was hast
Kannst du sagen
Hey Jungs
Ich hab meine Klappe
Und ich will euch ein anderes Angebot vorlegen
Was geht denn bei euch noch
Und dann werden die wahrscheinlich denken
Wir haben doch kein Geld
Das letzte Jahr war so schlecht
Die Geschäfte liefen schlecht
Corona war schlecht
Und jetzt die Inflation
Wie kannst du so gemein zu uns sein
Und jetzt sagen du willst mehr Geld
Und wenn du nicht mehr Geld bekommst
Dann gehst du auch noch
Das kann durchaus sein
Dass sie dann ein bisschen Panik schieben
Und so tun als bist du da ganz böse
Aber unterm Strich
Sie werden dir entweder ein besseres Angebot machen
Und wenn du es da ganz gut findest
Nimmst es an
Ansonsten gehst du woanders hin
Ich verstehe
Dass es Überwindung kostet
Ich kann euch das wirklich
Aus eigener Erfahrung sagen
Ich bin faul as fuck
Ihr kennt mich mit der Zeit Leute
Ich bin der faulste Mensch
Den es so gibt
Auf der Welt
Und es war für mich wirklich eine Überwindung
Mich woanders zu bewerben
Oder mich überhaupt mit dem Thema auseinander zu setzen
Oder mich überhaupt um das Thema zu kümmern
Not wrong Lulwe
Ja guck mal
Wie lange sage ich schon
Dass ich meine Dot-Files hochlade
Wie lange will ich meine Dot-Files schon hochladen
Drei Wochen und ich habe es nicht gemacht
Und ich bin faul as fuck
Und ich habe da wirklich keinen Bock drauf gehabt
Ich habe die bei mir auf der Arbeit genervt
Was Geld angeht
Was Homeoffice angeht
Und es hat sich einfach nichts getan
Und irgendwann war es halt so groß
Und der Abfuck auch so groß
Dass ich gesagt habe
Ich gucke mich jetzt um
Dazu beigetragen hat noch mein
Ähm
Kollege mit dem ich außerhalb von der Firma
Eigentlich auch so ganz gut verstehe
Weil ich von dem wusste
Der will auch weg
Der bewirbt sich auch woanders
Das war für mich der Anschluss zu sagen
Weißt du was Max
Wenn der abhaut
Hast du eigentlich wirklich keinen Bock mal da zu bleiben
Ähm
Da habe ich dann
Da habe ich dann angefangen
Und ich weiß
Das kostet Überwindung
Aber
Es ist
Nicht
Irgendwie super aufwendig oder so
Also den Lebens
Ihr müsst den Lebenslauf schreiben
Das ist ein bisschen nervig
Da müsst ihr euch ein bisschen mit
Mit
Sätze, Text, Bearbeitung deiner Art einsetzen
Da müsst ihr ein bisschen Wörter
Vorlagen basteln
Und ladet euch was im Internet runter
Oder ihr könnt auch
Das mit Latex machen
Und das irgendwie schön setzen
Oder in
Meinetwegen in
In Photoshop
Wo ihr Bock drauf habt
Ihr müsst eine Bewerbung
Ihr müsst einen Lebenslauf schreiben
Den möglichst
Ansprechenden
Das braucht mal
Einen Nachmittag Arbeit
Und ein paar Tage
Feintuning
So mehrere
Und mehrere Tage verteilt
Mit ein bisschen Feedback von neun
Ihr müsst den Lebenslauf schreiben
Aber Lebenslauf schreiben
Ist tatsächlich das anstrengendste
An der ganzen Geschichte
Und ihr könnt euch ja dafür auch eine Vorlage kaufen
Oder runterladen
Das ist
Und der Rest
Ohne Mist
Die
Ich
Ich kann es nur aus dem berichten
Was ich jetzt gemacht habe
Die Bewerbungsprozesse sind mittlerweile wirklich easy as fuck
Also
Ihr könnt euch bei nahezu allem online
Ebenso
hat von wann bis wann, aber so wirklich
eine Auflistung an Skills finde ich
auch zur Einschätzung für die ganz gut
und dass sie auch sehen, das passt zu der Stelle
Skill ist der Lebenslauf
und dann, je nachdem
ob ihr da jemand
kennt oder ob ihr euch da so
ein bisschen anschreiben vielleicht
noch, aber das ist
gar kein großer Akt
das ist überhaupt kein großer Akt, sich zu bewerben
und der weitere Vorteil ist
nicht nur, dass ihr rausbekommt
was denn so aktuell
so der Wert ist
den IT-Experten haben in eurem
Bereich, ne
ihr habt noch einen weiteren Vorteil, ihr lernt
mal wieder ein bisschen
Vorstellungsgespräche
führen
das ist, dass es so plötzlich anhört
das ist schon ein bisschen Übungssache
also ich mein, ich hab jetzt
drei Stück gehabt
bis ich den neuen Vertrag unterschrieben hab
das erste hat nicht hingehauen
weil erst
ich Corona hatte, dann mein Ansprechpartner
dort Corona hat und am Ende haben sie gemeint
ah, sie wollen dieses Jahr doch niemand haben, okay
ja, bei den anderen hab ich
einen Vertrag in der Post gehabt und jetzt hab ich
bei den anderen, bei den noch anderen hab ich unterschrieben
ja, was auch gut ist
GitHub, GitHub-Profil und sowas, wenn man
Projekte hat, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht
so schlimm, als wären Vorstellungsgespräche
als wären Vorstellungsgespräche so schwer, weil
ihr müsst euch jetzt überlegen, ihr seid in der besten
Situation, ihr habt einen festen
Job, vielleicht nicht einen, den
ihr wahnsinnig super geil findet
und für immer machen wollt, aber ihr habt einen festen Job
das heißt, ihr könnt
euch bedenkenlos bewerben
und wenn es nicht klappt, ist egal
da könnt ihr sagen, okay, hat nicht gepasst, hat mir nicht gefallen
denen hat es nicht gefallen
und ihr könnt es als Erfahrung
verbuchen, die
euch in Zukunft was bringt, weil
wenn ihr dann mal lernt
was das, was
ihr quasi wert seid, vielleicht auch
ein bisschen Erfahrung habt, was Vorstellungsgespräche
und sowas angeht
da könnt ihr vielleicht auch nochmal eine Runde mit eurem
Chef reden und es klappt dann besser
aber wie gesagt, ich würde es gar nicht
ich würde es, wie gesagt, nicht öffentlich machen, dass ich
mich bewerbe woanders, bis ich was
bis ich was Handfestes in der
in der Tasche hab
beziehungsweise halt was zum Unterschreiben hab
also was ich
hingeschickt hab, ich mach demnächst noch ein Video, wo ich
mein Lebenslauf, Skillliste und sowas schreibe
was ich hingeschickt habe, ist folgendes
Moment
ich kann es euch jetzt nicht zeigen
aber ich werde mal, ich werde noch ein bisschen
vorlesen, also was ich hingeschrieben hab, ist
berufliche Erfahrung
hab ich hingeschrieben, also
2013 bis heute
2011 bis 2012
2010 bis 2011
hab ich hingeschrieben, Ausbildung
das hab ich unten drunter geschrieben, ich hab tatsächlich mit dem aktuellsten
zuerst angefangen
dann hab ich hingeschrieben, dass ich seit 2012
nebenberuflicher Web-Videoproduzent bin
zum ersten Mal, dass ich das erwähnt hab
dann hab ich hingeschrieben, ich hab mehrere
Obersource-Projekte auf GitHub und hab mein GitHub
mit verlinkt
bei den einzelnen beruflichen Erfahrungen hab ich bei den
Stationen, die ich in der Tat verwendet habe,
zwischendurch
noch hingeschrieben, wo ich mich mit
also was ich da so gemacht habe
zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel hab ich dann hingeschrieben
so hier, 2013 bis bla bla bla
meine Aufgaben waren
umsetzen, also ich lese euch das jetzt einfach
mal vor, ja, umsetzen und
Etablierung eines Infrastructure-as-Code
Release-Managements
für 3000 plus
Linux-Systeme, mithilfe
von Git, Puppet, Ansible, Terraform
und Formel
ähm
Linux-System-Engineering, Red Hat, Ubuntu
Hochverfügbarkeit, Ausfallsicherheit
Security, Containerisierung und Skalierung
Tool-Entwicklung, C-Sharp.net
Go-JavaScript
Konzeptionierung, Einführung
neue technische Dokumentation
Linux-Systeme
inklusive automatischem Datenimport
und weil noch ein bisschen Platz war
hab ich hingeschrieben, Migration von Jenkins
auf GitHub Actions
was ich eigentlich
zwar gemacht habe, aber jetzt kein Hauptbestandteil ist
aber irgendwie war da noch ein bisschen Platz, ja
sowas hab ich da reingeschrieben
zum Beispiel, ich mach da noch demnächst
ein Video drüber, wo wir uns das mal zusammen angucken
so, so, so viel dazu
ein World-ETF
sonst nix
dann ist dann Teamleiter-Kacke
dann konnte es sich richtig
verkaufen, also dass man
vielleicht
nicht
bei allem hundertprozentig
immer zustimmt, aber wenn ein Teamleiter
mit was ankommt, sollte sich auf jeden Fall schon
was tun, es sei denn
und das darf, das kann natürlich auch sein
dass das Taktik ist
man sollte da wirklich
manchmal mit dem Schlimmsten rechnen, es kann durchaus sein
dass das Taktik ist, so nach dem Motto
dass dein Teamleiter und der Bereichsleiter
unter einer Decke stecken und die sich
ausgemacht haben, okay, es gibt
nicht mehr Geld und damit
du bei deinen Leuten nicht schlecht
dastehst, sagen wir denen einfach
ich hätte es abgelehnt
das kann durchaus auch sein, ja, oder
dein Teamleiter sagt einfach und kann es nicht richtig verkaufen
das meiste, wie die
gucken werden, wenn du sagst, ich habe einen anderen Vertrag
auf dem Tisch liegen, da werden sie dann
wieder rumjammern, so nach dem Motto, oh es war
so schlecht und Corona und oh
die Geschäftszahlen und jetzt willst du
auch noch gehen, oh mein Gott, aber da hätten
sie sich anderweitig überlegen müssen, oder sie können
einfach mehr Geld auf den Tisch legen, die Leute
sind ja letztendlich bestechbar
bestechlich, alle Leute, die in die
Arbeiten gehen, machen das, zumindest zu einem
nicht unerheblichen Teil, ich will nicht sagen, nur
aber nicht zu einem unerheblichen Teil, weil
sie Geld verdienen, weil sie keinen Bock haben
unter der Brücke schlafen zu müssen
das ist eigentlich die beste Antwort, die man geben könnte, so nach dem
Motto, ja, Herr Max
was hat sie dazu gebracht, sich bei uns
zu bewerben, ja, ich möchte essen und
nicht unter der Brücke schlafen müssen
natürlich kannst du das nicht sagen
natürlich musst du dir irgendwie einen Scheiß aus den
Fingern saugen, ja
aber du könntest auch eine ehrliche
Antwort geben, ich will Geld verdienen
und es gibt ja sicherlich
oftmals auch noch andere Gründe, aber
für viele ist es bestimmt auch der Hauptgrund
sie wollen schlicht und ergreifend Geld verdienen
ey,
was ist das für eine bescheide Aussage
Darkseid schreibt, er hatte einige Bewerbungen
eigentlich wollte ich noch ein paar Youtube-Videos kommen, aber wir haben ja noch schon eine Zeit
ähm, er hatte einige Bewerbungsgespräche jetzt
und ich habe das Gefühl, man durchläuft mittlerweile mindestens
zwei bis vier Gespräche, früher hat man das
also
gut, wie gesagt, meine Erfahrung hält sich in Grenzen
ich habe mich jetzt mich dreimal beworben
einmal hatte ich nur ein Gespräch
dort, wo ich einen Vertrag auf dem Tisch liegen hatte, hatte ich zwei Gespräche
das erste Gespräch war mit dem
mit einem von den Personen, ähm, mit dem
mit dem, ähm, mit dem, ähm, mit dem
mit dem, mit einem von der Persona-
mit einer von der Personalabteilung
mit dem, ja, keine Ahnung
Bereichsabteilungsleiter und meinem
zukünftigen Teamleiter
äh, remote ging das ganze über Teams
und dann hatte ich noch ein zweites Gespräch mit denen vor Ort
und danach habe ich einen Vertrag gekriegt
mit dort, wo ich jetzt unterschrieben
habe, ging das tatsächlich
sehr schnell, da habe ich genau
ein Gespräch, ok, ich habe vorher ganz
kurz telefoniert mit ihm
und dann hatte ich vor Ort ein Gespräch und dann habe ich einen Vertrag
gekriegt, das ging mega schnell
was das Thema heute ist, das Thema heute
ist, dass es kein Thema gibt
ich widme mich euren Problemen
bzw. wir gucken uns gleich
noch eine Stunde lang irgendwie ein paar
Youtube-Videos an und dann gehe ich ins Bett
ich habe jetzt so lange nicht gestreamt, ich musste jetzt einfach mal
wieder online kommen und ich hatte heute Abend
auch wirklich Bock drauf, mal wieder Stream einzuschalten
hab mir gedacht, warum, warum sollte ich
MMO-Kreiselgrind machen, wenn ich auch
Prime-Subs abgreifen kann
haben wir schon
Knojector, dankeschön für den
Prime-Satz, äh Prime-Sub
und
ich habe keine Ahnung
wie ich das betonen soll,
Hjimk
Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub, wie auch immer
weil er so genau ausspricht
Headlock, Polka-Subscript
und 8 Monate, jetzt bin ich
happy, jetzt gab es
so viele Prime-Subs
und du hast den
Diamantkeks unlockt
ja, kannst du machen
also Arbeitszeugnis anfordern ist
prinzipiell keine schlechte Idee
die haben bei mir nicht sehr viel Wert draufgelegt
aber es war doch ganz gut, dass ich eins hatte
also wie gesagt, den habe ich mich ja
lange genug jetzt darüber aushalten, du musst
keinen Schiss haben, gerade wenn du in der IT tätig bist
ein bisschen Plan hast, ja
so sieht es aus, wir müssen
das Gegenteil von Schiss haben, wir müssen
Anti-Schiss haben, als
Rollout-Manager, ich habe keine Ahnung, was
ein Rollout-Manager sein soll, ich meine, ich kann mir natürlich
was darunter zusammen reimen, du kümmerst
dich wahrscheinlich um Updates
oder sowas, um
Package-Updates, neue
Software-Releases
Patch-Management, keine Ahnung, was das sein muss
also das müssen die ja schon reinschreiben
was die denn unter einem Rollout-Manager verstehen
ansonsten kann das ja alles bedeuten
es ist eh Schall und Rauch
wie die ganzen Berufs, wie die ganzen Jobs
heißen, da denkt sich
eh jeder was anderes aus
würdest du einem Berufseinsteiger eine 100%
Remote-Stelle empfehlen?
Das ist eine gute Frage
puh, das ist eine gute Frage, also
also
ich bin mir nicht 100% sicher, aber
wenn es eine Stelle ist
die du nur annehmen kannst
weil sie eben Remote
ist, dann warum nicht
also zum Beispiel du wohnst jetzt in München und nimmst
eine Stelle in Berlin an oder
wohnst in Frankfurt und nimmst eine Stelle in Berlin an
warum nicht?
ich meine, da kannst du ja vor Ort
gar nicht hin
und dann finde ich das auch
nicht verwerflich zu sagen
oder was heißt verwerflich?
da finde ich das auch nicht irgendwie blöd zu sagen
ich mach das nicht
nur weil es 100% Remote ist
da spricht eigentlich nichts dagegen
ich denke eh, dass in Zukunft
noch mehr Unternehmen
auch anfangen werden 100%
Remote-Stellen rauszuhauen, es gibt jetzt schon viele
auch durch Corona
vor Corona war es ja noch gar nicht
manche sind jetzt wieder ein bisschen am zurückrufen
aber gerade wie der IT-Jobmarkt
aussieht, die werden sich das nicht leisten können
das durchzuhalten
ja, warum nicht
insgesamt
würde ich sagen
es ist nicht verkehrt
wenn man ein bisschen
Enterprise
Business Luft
vor Ort schon
mitbekommen hat, auch für die Zukunft
ich würde nicht sagen, dass das unbedingt notwendig
ist, also wenn du eine gute erste Stelle
100% Remote hast, die in einer anderen Stadt ist
die nur Remote geht
sprich überhaupt nichts dagegen
wird dir niemand irgendwie negativ auslegen
oder so
aber ich glaube auf lange Sicht
zumindest mal ein bisschen
so die Business Enterprise Luft
wie das so ist
mal mitbekommen zu haben
ist glaube ich gar nicht so verkehrt
das muss ja kein 100%
offline
kein 100%
vor Ort Job sein
das würde ich heutzutage auch nicht mehr machen
und einmal die Woche
alle 14 Tage ins Büro
oder sowas ist nicht verkehrt
wenn das
die Lage der Stelle zulässt
dass man ein bisschen was
mal mitbekommen hat
wenn man danach für sich entscheidet
hey, ich hab da überhaupt keinen Bock drauf
und ich will überhaupt gar nichts mit Leuten da vor Ort
zu tun haben, dann kann man sich ja nach wie vor immer auf 100%
Remote Sachen bewerben
aber ab und zu mal so ein bisschen
so die Enterprise Business Welt
mitbekommen zu haben
ist glaube ich gar nicht so verkehrt
benutzt Xing überhaupt noch jemand?
braucht man ein Trägerwort
dass die Anfragen kommen
ja du solltest
Senior Chief Cloud
Solution
Native Blockchain
Engineer sein
dann klappt das
ey du kannst da
reinschreiben was der Realität entspricht
Architekt
natürlich, nicht Engineer
Architekt, klar
Expert Architekt
stimmt, die Anfragen willst du nicht haben
das ist auch wiederum
ne, ich würde einfach die Skills reinschreiben
die der Realität entsprechen
weil du willst ja auch Sachen machen
auf die du Bock hast
man kann es natürlich schon schön verkaufen
so ist das nicht
was ich zum Beispiel
gut fand, da ich gesagt habe
ich habe 15 Jahre Erfahrung in der Frankfurter
Finanzbranche
was ja so ist, normalerweise
ohne euch Leute wäre ich gar nicht auf die Idee gekommen
das reinzuschreiben, das hat sich hier im Chat so ergeben
dass ich auf die Idee gekommen bin
ich könnte das reinschreiben, weil das ist ja kein Skill
im eigentlichen Sinne
ich meine es ist kein Skill 15 Jahre in irgendeinem Bereich
gewesen zu sein
aber ich habe es trotzdem reingeschrieben
und das kam gut an
ich meine im Nachhinein verständlich
weil ich bin
ich habe 15 Jahre Erfahrung in der Frankfurter Finanzbranche
und ich
bin weiterhin tätig in der Frankfurter
Finanzbranche, also kann ich irgendwo
schon verstehen, dass ich das ganz gut fand
du hast ab dem 1.3. einen neuen Job
in der Softwareentwicklung hat jemand
etwas nervös
das ist nicht schlimm, ein bisschen nervös zu sein, das ist mein Tipp
das macht überhaupt nichts
ein bisschen nervös sein
ist besser als der gechillteste Typ
und dann noch irgendwie blöde Sprüche machen
ein bisschen nervös schadet nicht
es ist normal, dass man ein bisschen nervös ist
wenn man neue Sachen macht
ich meine, wenn du jetzt nicht
wie dieser Schwitz
Meme Typ
dieses Schwitzer Meme
Kerl aussiehst
dem das komplett so wasserfallmäßig
runterläuft
ist alles ok
ja, ist tatsächlich so
und das ist auch so
das ist auch so
müssen sie ja auch
guck mal
realistisch betrachtet hat doch ein Unternehmen
3 Varianten
um Leute
zu bekommen
das erste ist und die einfachste Variante ist
nichts machen
um die Leute mit Geld zu kacken
dann bekommst du auch Leute
du musst nur genug bezahlen
also einfach Fett, Kohle reinbuttern
ist das erste
das zweite ist
sich irgendwie attraktiver machen
es kann ja durchaus sein, dass das Unternehmen schon attraktiv ist
aber die Stellenanzeigen bloß beschissen sind
das kommt
bestimmt öfter vor als man denkt
also
dass sie das einfach
attraktiver gestalten
was wollte ich jetzt sagen
genau
es gibt 3 Sachen
was Unternehmen machen können
ich kann nicht Chat lesen
und dabei reden
das kriege ich einfach nicht gebacken
ich habe jetzt wieder die Hälfte vergessen
fällt mir bestimmt gleich wieder ein
achso
ja ich weiß wieder
es gibt 3 Varianten was Unternehmen ja machen können
um Leute zu bekommen
sie können ja Geld bezahlen
sich attraktiver machen
oder sie können einfach
radikal ihre Ansprüche herunterschrauben
so nach dem Motto
hey wir haben ja einen komplizierten Job
den lassen wir jetzt einfach jeden machen
und
am Ende wird es wahrscheinlich
eine Kombination aus allen 3 sein
die werden mehr bezahlen müssen
die werden sich attraktiver machen müssen
und
die werden ihre Ansprüche herunterschrauben müssen
wenn sie IT Leute haben wollen
weil wenn sie das nicht machen
dann arten die anderen 2 Punkte halt aus
also ich sehe es bei mir
dort wo ich gerade arbeite
bei uns
versuchen sie
die Stellenanzeigen
attraktiver zu gestalten
sie bezahlen
nicht mehr Geld
was auch dazu beiträgt
dass sie keine Leute finden
und sie haben ihre Ansprüche drastisch
herunterschraubt
was man daran sieht
das ist jetzt wirklich kein Witz
der arme kann da nichts für
die haben ihm das so erzählt
dass eine Stelle
wo früher Linux Administration
Administratoren gesucht wurden
was auch sinnvoll ist
wenn man nämlich eine komplette
Umgebung hat mit tausenden von Linux Systemen
dass dort mittlerweile
Leute eingestellt werden
die keine Ahnung von Linux haben
und die das auch nicht in der Bewerbung
stehen haben und das auch im Vorstellungsgespräch
sagen dass sie keine Ahnung von Linux haben
sondern sich nur sagen wir mal mit
Windows auskennen oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen
also sie haben ihre Ansprüche so weit
runtergeschraubt dass sie für eine
Stelle die eigentlich Linux
Know How voraussetzt
Leute einstellen ohne Linux Erfahrung
das muss nicht zwangsläufig schlimm sein
solange du Leute einstellst
die fähig sind und bereit sind
sich neue Sachen anzugucken
aber da sieht man schon also
die müssen auch ihren Anspruch
runterschrauben
bei euch müssen 6500 Leute gehen
krass aber wahrscheinlich nicht
alles in der IT
und selbst wenn es alles in der IT wäre
das wäre ja nur ein Tropfen auf den heißen Stein
versus die offenen unbesetzten
Stellen
aber wenn das fähige Leute sind
sind die ratzfatz unter
du fängst am 1. oder am 11.4
am 1.4
du bekommst
40-45% mehr
da seht ihr mal Leute was da alles drin ist
das ist ein riesen Gehaltssprung
den werdet ihr so
also ich gehe mal davon aus gleiche Arbeitszeit wie vorher
beim gleichen Arbeitgeber auf gar keinen Fall haben
gut
ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr
weil
dafür ist es bei mir schon in der Summe zuviel
ich meine
ich hätte da nichts dagegen
aber die werden mir nicht einfach 150k bezahlen
oder sowas
man kann es ja irgendwie übertreiben
ähm
wobei
ich meine nehmen würde ich es natürlich
ja
da sieht man da ist einiges drin
bubblos ist faul das ist richtig
ne ich würde nicht
ich würde nicht die erstbeste Lebenslaufvorlage nehmen
ich würde mir schon eine aus dem Internet holen
die ein bisschen zu euch passt
und jetzt auch vielleicht nicht
das erste Google Ergebnis
also ich habe auch
eine Wordvorlage die habe ich nicht aus dem Internet
die habe ich von einem Arbeitskollege
der sich beworben hat und die fand ich
ganz hübsch und habe ihn gefragt ob ich die nehmen kann
also auch was da angeht
ultra faul
es werden überall händeringend
Leute gesucht was IT angeht
und das stimmt schon du hast recht
nicht nur IT aber von anderen Bereichen
habe ich halt keine Ahnung
die 10er KD in Battlefield
muss auch in die Skilllist
nicht nur aus Battlefield
auch die Warzone Wins
zeigt immerhin was du für ein guter
Teamplayer online bist
Open Source Referenzen sind auf jeden Fall sinnvoll
also ich habe
mein GitHub Profil mit verwendet
verlinkt
und halt eine Skillliste
hingeschickt aber wir gucken uns das alles zusammen
in dem Video an
was sollte man machen wenn in der Firma wirklich alles
perfekt ist jedoch das Gehalt
ist jetzt nicht schlecht mit einem neuen Job
um 20-30% gesteigert werden könnte
ey
du musst dich erst mal fragen ob
ob du irgendwelche Sachen
aktuell nicht machen kannst aufgrund
des Gehaltes
also wenn du dein Leben
so leben kannst wie du willst
wenn du da keine großen Einschränkungen machen willst
wenn du nicht irgendwelche Sachen vorhast
wo du sagst dafür brauche ich 20-30% mehr
und ansonsten alles perfekt ist
bleib halt da
was jetzt nicht heißt
dass du nicht dort versuchen kannst
ein bisschen mehr Geld rauszuholen
welches Video ist gemeint
kommt noch
dass ich noch ein Video mache mit meinem Lebenslauf
und Skillliste und für meine Bewerbung
dass ihr euch das mal angucken könnt
natürlich muss ich ein paar Sachen schwärzen
also so würde ich es handhaben
ich würde mich fragen
also habe ich
also will ich irgendwas machen
wo mir die Kohle nicht für reicht
gibt es irgendwelche Einschränkungen
die ich jetzt habe die ich da nicht machen muss
ansonsten
wenn du top zufrieden bist
und dein Gehalt ok ist
und du jetzt nichts hast
wo du sagst ich brauche die 20-30%
Geld unbedingt
mehr dann würde ich einfach da bleiben
weil
Geld ist
mit Sicherheit
der wichtigste Faktor was Jobs angeht
für viele
aber nicht der einzige
du musst dir halt überlegen
ob das das aufwiegen würde
was es
jetzt nicht ausschließt ist
dass du dich trotzdem woanders mal umguckst
ich meine vielleicht findest du ja auch was
was dir wirklich gut gefällt
wo du sagst hey
das ist ähnlich nice
oder macht zumindest einen ähnlich guten Eindruck
so in der Bewerbung sieht das oftmals ja alles
viel geiler aus als es am Ende ist
ich mach mir da auch keine Illusion
dass dort in die Versicherung wo ich jetzt wechsle
dass dort alles perfekt sein wird
auch wenn es nicht gut angehört hat
es gibt immer Sachen die dich aufregen
aber ich meine es sollte dich jetzt nicht davon abhalten
nicht mal umzugucken
spricht ja wirklich nichts dagegen
und wenn du was findest was dir gefällt
und mehr Geld bezahlen
vielleicht ist es ja auch was
und ich meine vielleicht
noch ein bisschen mehr Geld raushandeln
bei deinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber
wo dir alles so gut gefällt und da bleiben
aber wenn es dir gefällt und das Geld nicht brauchst
und so rundum zufrieden bist
auch mit deinem Gehalt
musst du einfach auch gar nichts machen
erfreue dich des Lebens
und sei happy
und mach dir nicht so viele Gedanken
dass du irgendwo 20% mehr kriegen könntest
Fake Git History
könntest du auch machen
Problem ist nur dass in Fake Git History
halt nichts drin ist
das sind alles Projekte
4 Tage Woche ist tatsächlich was
was ich jedem empfehlen kann
wenn es den
Gehaltsverlust
wenn man das
ja irgendwie aushält
4 Tage Woche ist das beste was es gibt
das ist zwar nur 1 Tag mehr frei
aber der wiegt viel mehr als 1 Tag
habe ich mir schon oft drüber ausgelassen
ja das ist bei allen
die labern alle plötzlich
wie gesagt gute Führungskräfte sind rar gesät
mir ist gerade was runtergefallen
was nicht gut ist
dass mir es runtergefallen ist
weil
das ist wirklich doof
habe ich mein Handy mit der Lampe
weil
wenn ich da drauf trete
ah da ist es
so ein Stück Draht
ich muss mal kurz unter den Tisch krabbeln
wenn ich da drauf trete
beziehungsweise
das irgendwie mit meinem Fuß rumschiebe
dann habe ich es wieder im Fuß stecken
hattet ihr schon mal einen
Pinheader im Fußstehen stecken
wahrscheinlich nicht
ich kann euch auch nicht raten
das zu machen
um es mal auszuprobieren
ich mein sowas hier
also ich gehe davon aus
die meisten von euch klingt richtig dumm
ja ist es auch
ist es auch
das ist richtig dumm
sowas passiert zum Beispiel
wenn ihr an eurem Schreibtisch
auch ein bisschen rum bastelt
und euch fällt sowas runter
und irgendwann sitzt ihr da
vielleicht mit Socken
oder nackigen Füßen sogar
und wedelt mit euren Füßen
unterm Tisch auf dem Teppich rum
und das Ding verkantet sich
und ihr habt es dann auf einmal im Zeh stecken
oder in der Ferse
in der Ferse hatte ich es
stimmt gar nicht
ich hatte es in der Ferse nicht im Zeh
in der Ferse stecken
und es hat ein ganz ekliges Geräusch gemacht
man hat richtig so
alles gemacht
und in dem Moment wo ich dieses Geräusch gehört habe
wusste ich in ca. 250 Millisekunden tut es weh
also ich habe das schneller gehört
und
den
ich habe
die Berührung
und den Sound schneller gespürt
als es weh getan hat
es ist nicht schön sowas
es macht keinen Spaß
es ist jetzt keine krasse Verletzung
wo du ins Krankenhaus musst
aber das ist unangenehm sowas im Fuß stecken zu haben
wie ist das denn
also weil mir der Draht runtergefallen ist
genau
deshalb Sicherheitsschuhe
hast du Sicherheitsschuhe daheim am Schreibtisch an
nee
du kannst Zwischenzeugnisse beantragen
das muss dir dein Arbeitgeber zwar nicht ausstellen
aber es gibt
bestimmte Ereignisse
da steht dir eins zu
zum Beispiel
Vorgesetztenwechsel
oder Führungskräftewechsel
oder aber
das ist das wo der Arbeitgeber relativ schlecht ablehnen kann
ist
Aufgabengebiet
Änderungen, Erweiterungen
und nachdem sich in der IT die Aufgabengebiete laufen
irgendwie erweitern und ändern
ist es relativ easy da mein Arbeitszeugnis zu kriegen
wirst du eigentlich Hogwarts Legacy spielen
ok
ich werde es nicht spielen
und nicht weil es Leute triggern würde
sondern weil mich Harry Potter nicht interessiert
wobei ich
bei dem ganzen Rumgeflame auf Twitter
kurzzeitig den Reflex verspüre
dass ich mir doch gekauft habe
es als reine Trotzreaktion zu kaufen
aber es war mir dann doch nicht
irgendwie interessant genug
dass ich es mir doch gekauft hätte
und mittlerweile musst du ja schon Angst haben
wenn du da spielst
dass irgendwie eine Horde Leute um die Ecke kommt
und dich belästigt
legst auf Twitter streamen
genau
ich kaufe mir doch kein Game
was ich gar kein Interesse habe zu spielen
ein Kobold Compiler
oh ja das ist nice das brauche ich unbedingt
Otterkit
Otterkit Kobold Compiler
Reopen Source Compiler
von Kobold.net Plattform
nice Leute
ich wollte schon immer mal Kobold auf
.net haben
Patrick da hast du recht
das ist wirklich lost ich habe es nicht gemacht
ich war ich war
ich würde nicht sagen kurz davor
aber ich habe so das Verlangen verspürt
ok man kann wirklich
Kobold auf
gibt sicherlich die ein oder anderen 85 jährigen Kobold Fans
ja genau so sieht es aus
habe ich auch letztens schon im Stream erzählt
das ist der beste beste Tipp den man geben kann
wenn man Zwischenzeugnis haben will
ich habe keine Ahnung
wenn die Firma eine gute Kantine hat gehe ich jeden Tag dahin
selbst dann würde ich nicht jeden Tag in die Firma
wir haben eine ganz gute Kantine
die auch subventioniert ist
es kostet trotzdem noch ein bisschen Geld
ist nicht komplett umsonst
aber ich gehe trotzdem nicht jeden Tag in die Firma
MIT und Cambridge
ich glaube das ist für die meisten hier in Deutschland
eher nicht das was sie machen wollen
ich meine klar wenn du den
den krassen Karriere Grind machen willst
und da
das wie heißt das
das Grindset Mindset hast
dann mach das
da musst du aber auch erstmal aufgenommen werden
und dann ist mit in Deutschland
bleiben nix erstmal
ABAP
ist ABAP
ist das SAP?
hab ich in zwei Unis gefragt
und dann
ABAP ist SAP
damit kann man gut Geld verdienen
hab auch schon von einigen SAP
Consultants gehört
die fette Kohle mit heimschleppen
also
es mag jetzt bestimmt nicht
das geilste zum entwickeln sein
aber Geldtechnisch
ist es bestimmt nicht verkehrt
ich habe gehört
dass HL7 Entwickler dringend gesucht werden
Leute ich gebe es zu
wenn ich nicht total dumm dastehe
habe ich offscreen gerade gegoogelt
was HL7 ist
ich wollte natürlich den obligatorischen
Halflife Joke bringen
aber der ist mittlerweile ausgelutscht
das ist irgendein
irgendein Standard zum Austausch
zwischen Medizinplattformen
mehr weiß ich nicht
ok wenn ein neuer Kollege kommt
bekommt man
der in der Regel deutlich mehr Kohle
letztlich muss man
ja gut
das spricht aber nicht unbedingt für die Firma
wenn sie auf die bestehenden Leute scheissen
und
den neuen massig viel Geld geben
ich meine die müssen den neuen heute
viel mehr bieten vielleicht
aber
man sollte sich zumindest auch mal überlegen
möchte man denn nicht die Leute halten
die schon da sind und Ahnung vom System haben
weil egal wie gut
jetzt mal Real Talk
egal wie gut Dokumentation ist
wie gut die Prozesse sind, wie gut das Projekt ist
wie gut das Projektmanagement ist
es wird immer
und das geht auch gar nicht anders
es wird immer Kopfwissen geben
und Leute die nach Jahren gehen
und viel mitbekommen haben
sind immer ein Verlust für die Firma
egal wie gut der Rest drum herum ist
das heißt es wäre bescheuert
auf die bestehenden Leute zu kacken
und dann nix zu machen
aber gut vielleicht sackt die Firma halt aus
kann ja auch sein
man sollte das so machen
wie dieser Python Typ heute auf
man sollte einfach immer
immer nur die Sachen verwenden
die gut sind
und dann ist das kein Problem mehr
und ich meine keine Fehler programmieren
hat schon mal einen großen Vorteil
man braucht auch keine Tests
man braucht auch keine Dokumentation und keine Comments
einfach keine Fehler mehr
just for head
einfach keine Fehler programmieren
holy lucky gamers dankeschön für den Prime Sub
zweiter Monat Poggers
bald hast du den ersten Keks Unlocked
wobei ich glaube du hast schon den zweiten Keks Unlocked
der erste ist ja der Holzkeks
Holzlieger
tja naja gut
ich kann dir sagen wie es aktuell bei uns läuft
also dort wo ich aktuell arbeite
die haben ihren Anspruch so weit runter geschraubt
dass sie in Positionen wo es eigentlich
mit um Lienungsadministration geht
mittlerweile Leute einstellen
die keine Lienungserfahrung haben
so und
dann halt auch Leute
die vielleicht nicht unbedingt die aller krasseste
Motivation haben was zu lernen
wann gibt es neue Emotes
neue Emote gab es erst vor einem Monat
oder so paar neue Emotes
aber es muss neue Badges
geben da hast du recht
und die
tun sich wirklich schwer die haben nicht wirklich
viel Bock sich mit Lienungs auseinanderzusetzen
und dort
weiß
ich nicht ob er die Probezeit
übersteht
aber letztendlich kann sich die Firma wahrscheinlich auch nicht
leisten
hat jemand eine gute Methode um seine Tabs aufzuräumen
bei mir hat sich ein bisschen was
angesammelt
da kann ich jetzt nicht draufklicken
weil ich die Vorschau mir nicht angucken kann
ah ne hier
ok zeig mal wie viele Tabs hast du
so viele Tabs
hast du doch gar nicht
oh
das ist gefotoshopt oder
das hast du gefotoshopt
denn die einfachste
Variante
ist ja immer noch die hier
aber das wirst du wahrscheinlich nicht wollen
du willst ja wahrscheinlich ein paar Sachen
die ihr merken
ansonsten würde ich sagen einfach nicht aufräumen und weitermachen
für irgendwas braucht man ja seinen Arbeitsspeicher
guckte mal
das ist traurig
es ist traurig
guckt euch das mal an
moment
warum habe ich 31 GIG in use
ich habe nichts offen
ich lecke critical information
über meinen Rechner glaube ich
ah ich habe die VM offen
ich habe die VM offen
aber die VM braucht auch nicht so viel
die VM braucht
5G
ach cached
ok ich habe nur 12 belegt
das macht mehr Sinn
ich habe nur 12 belegt
aber ist trotzdem armselig
guck mal hier
ich habe trotz 2 laufenden VMs und Chrome Tabs
ich habe nur die Hälfte meines RAMs belegt
da geht noch was
da geht noch ordentlich
nur die Hälfte ist voll
das Video mache ich demnächst
mit Bewerbung und Skillliste
und Jobsuche und so was ich dahin geschickt habe
morgen gibt es ein Video
zur Emulator Kiste
richtig gut geschnitten
das vom Tyler wieder
der hat mein Gelaber ein bisschen zusammengeschnitten
nicht aus dem Stream ich habe noch zusätzlich was eingesprochen
richtig gut gemacht
lässt sich nice angucken
wäre es nicht super mega geil wenn man
einen Lebenslauf als Web App hat
prinzipiell ja
das Problem ist nur
dass man sprechen muss
dass die Personalabteilung keine Ahnung von Technik hat
und es eventuell irgendwelche internen Workflows gibt
wo die Bewerbung als PDFs ausgetauscht werden
oder als Dokumente ausgetauscht werden
das heißt an sich eine coole Idee
ähm
praktisch
vielleicht schwierig
je nach Firma
machst du noch Videos über Stellen ausschreiben
ich würde gerne Feedback zu unsere erhalten
du kannst
ich habe noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit
also wenn du die hier öffentlich posten willst
die in Verbindung bringen kann
kannst du einfach in Chat posten
wir können die gleich mal angucken
dann kann es natürlich auch sein
dass der Chat sich ein bisschen drüber auslässt
aber der Chat ist ja meistens
voll
vollkommen harmlos
stimmt's
was ich jetzt denke
ja kann man machen
oh ja nice
auch gleich im Doppelpack
das ist natürlich dann doppel nice
wo war das mit Doppel plus gut
war das 1984
wo doppel plus gut
irgendwie
eigentlich eine Umschreibung war für
irgendwas anderes
krieg ich es nicht mehr genau zusammen
doppel plus gut
C doppel plus
oh please
so habe ich das noch gar nicht gesehen
also
zum Thema
es steht drinnen dass sie ein Studium wollen
da steht oftmals viel Käse drinnen
in Stellensanzeigen
Studium oder Ausbildung
oder vergleichbare Ausbildung
oder bla bla bla
ganz ehrlich
es ist scheiß egal
wenn du Berufserfahrung hast
ob du ein Studium oder eine Ausbildung gemacht hast
guck mal
ich mach den Kram jetzt seit 15 Jahren
das geht denen sonst wo vorbei
ob ich ein Studium gemacht habe
oder eine Ausbildung
solange ich das kann
was die haben wollen
wie heißt das
TV
wie heißt diese komische
Tarifgeschichte dort
da macht es vielleicht einen Unterschied
habe ich ja gerade schon beantwortet
kann ich das anklicken
ich habe das nur angeklickt weil du das geschrieben hast
ich weiß dass du schon öfters hier bist
und noch nie gebetet hast
ja das wird so kommen
wer weiß was in 40 Jahren
die Hypesprache ist
ich meine 40 Jahre
könnte ich mitkommen
da bin ich 78
Link habe ich gesehen
ich bin gleich
irgendwann demnächst soweit
korrekt
Mr Sedus
Mr 24
da ist das Ding
da habe ich schon den Sub
holy luck gamers
oder ich schon
ich habe bei uns schon Leute gesehen
die die Probezeit nicht überstanden haben
ich habe sogar Externe gesehen
die nach 2 Wochen wieder weg waren
weil sie 2 Wochen lang gebraucht haben
um ihren Rechner
um ihren Notebook einzurichten
wir hatten teilweise schon Leute
bei uns als externe Experten
wo ich die Frage also
wo da der Experte drinnen stecken soll
habe ich auch nicht verstanden
so
ist das deine
ne Quatsch
du heißt ja Patrick das kannst du nicht sein
was bin ich da sehend
sieht eigentlich gar nicht
sieht eigentlich gar nicht übel aus
ach das ist dein Bruder
ja also finde ich eigentlich ganz hübsch
sieht halt sehr technisch aus
weiß nicht ob das die Personalabteilung anspricht
ok also
Wunderpunkt Software Job
mach das mal kurz in der Vorschau auf
man weiß ja nie
ok alles klar legit
oh wisst ihr
wisst ihr was ich schon mal sehr gut finde
Dark Theme wenn man Dark Mode im
Browser aktiviert hat
ohne Dark Reader
das sammelt bei mir schon mal Pluspunkte Leute
findet ihr es nicht auch ausgesprochen
ausgesprochen
POG
dass es Dark Theme hat
wenn man Dark im
Betriebssystem und im Browser eingestellt hat
weil ich habe es gerade
bei mir im Browser aufgemacht
dort ist es Light Theme also sprich
guckt hier Achtung Brille Leute Brille
Sonnenbrille
es ist nice das ist gut das finde ich schon mal schön
so ok
Senior Frontend Entwickler
und Entwicklerin
attraktives Gehalt ab 4500 Euro
das finde ich schon mal
exzellent das das drinnen steht
man weiß zwar natürlich nicht
ob es 12 Monats Gehälter
13 oder 14 Monats Gehälter sind
aber ich vermute mal das ich es so ausgerechnet habe
das es wahrscheinlich 12 sind
würde ich jetzt mal von ausgehen
also ich würde es ja so rechnen
das es möglichst gut klingt ja
ja
das finde ich schon mal nice
das das so drinnen steht
plus Boni
ja plus Boni
weiß man ja nicht was es da alles gibt
aber das ist doch schon mal gut das es da steht
ich mein super krass viel ist es jetzt
net
das sind 12 mal
das sind 54k
das ist jetzt
ich weiß
ich kenne die Region nicht
für nen Senior
für nen Senior Entwickler
ich denke das ist durchaus ok
aber das ist jetzt nicht
irgendwie super
super in Sphären
das jetzt jeder sich da drum reißt
also
gerade wenn es ne Senior Position ist
und dementsprechend auch Leute
mit viel Berufserfahrung sucht
ist das jetzt schon nicht so der Wahnsinn
aber gut ich mein
letztendlich ist es eure Stellenanzeige
die ihr da für Budget habt
ich würde bloß sagen
für mich wäre es jetzt vielleicht bisschen wenig
es kommt natürlich darauf an es sei denn es sind
mega mega krasse Boni
kann ja auch sein
das es sich dann alles wieder ausgleicht
Budget für Weiterbildung und
Zertifizierung
ok das ist natürlich schon mal ein richtig
großer Pluspunkt
100% Remote und vor allem das es auch so drinnen steht
100%
Remote in unserem
unserem Büro in Köln
Coworking Space in deiner Nähe
ja also 100% Remote finde ich gut
dass ihr das gleich so offensiv reinschreibt
da weiß man nämlich Bescheid
zumal man sagen muss für viele Leute
ist denke ich
auch
je nach Gewichtung
Homeoffice was
was durchaus mehr zählt
als vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Geld
ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen
dass es Leute gibt die sagen ey
da verzichte ich sogar auf ein bisschen Kohle wenn ich 100% Homeoffice habe
also finde ich gut
dass das gleich offensiv so drinnen steht
ja gut stimmt
da steht ab davor
aber das ab
letztendlich kann man ja nach der Zahl gehen die da steht
so Top Hardware und freie
das finde ich auch super dass ihr das reinschreibt
also die Top Hardware ist ja
Definitionsfrage
aber freie Betriebssystem Auswahl
das finde ich eine super Geschichte
das wäre für mich ein sehr großer Pluspunkt
kann ich euch gleich sagen
für mich wäre das ein großer Pluspunkt
ich meine ich würde es nicht machen
wenn
das wäre jetzt kein Pluspunkt wenn ich
keinen Bock drauf hätte aus anderen Gründen zu sagen
ja deswegen mache ich es
aber obendrauf nochmal ist das eine super Geschichte
Homeoffice Setup
ist auch gut ja
keine Schmerzen
meinen Rechner dafür zu verwenden
aber wenn
freie Arbeitszeitwahl
und virtuelle Termine meistens nach Scrum
den Rest der Zeit kannst du selbstverantwortlich organisieren
hm
ich weiß jetzt nicht
wie ich es deuten würde
könnte natürlich auch heißen
dass es recht verplant ist
ja wenn es da keinen gibt
der Sachen organisiert
also ich würde es wahrscheinlich kritisch auslegen
wie es so geschrieben ist
ich kann jetzt ja immer nur sagen
wie es so auf mich spontan wirkt
das soll jetzt nicht heißen dass ich das irgendwie schlecht machen will
das ist jetzt bis jetzt schon besser als die meisten anderen Stellen
die ich so sehe
so ist es nicht
ich kann ja immer nur sagen wie es auf mich wirkt
das ist ja gut
dass es die Möglichkeit gibt
aber wenn ich alles selbst organisieren muss
und planen muss
dann stellt sich bei mir so die Frage
gibt es denn dann überhaupt irgendjemand
der dort ein bisschen was organisiert
weil ich bin ja IT Experte und kein Manager
Offen- und Lebenskultur siehe Werte
Arbeite an Softwaren
mit Teams in größten Formen ist okay
was erwartet dich?
wir sind ein Team aus talentierten
und hochmotivierten Software-Experten
welches gemeinsam mit unseren Kunden
in Software skalierbar und nachhaltig entwickelt
unsere Projekte laufen mindestens 3 Monate
im Normalfall jedoch
ist das eigentlich unbefristet?
das sehe ich
habe ich jetzt nichts zu gesehen
wenn ja würde ich das noch reinschreiben
ähm
gefällt dir ein Projekt
ich finde es ein interessatives Projekt für dich
okay
you build it, you run it
wir arbeiten interdisziplinär
und setzen dabei auf starke DevOps-Kulturen
um schneller und stärker auf Veränderungen Antworten zu geben
unser TechStack
für unsere Lösungen setzen wir auf verschiedene
wie soll denn ein Frontend-Engineer
auch komplett Runnen
wie soll das funktionieren
ich bin ja immer dafür
dass man sagt
man sollte über den Tellerrand hinausschauen
und
man sollte auch
auch als Anwendungsentwickler sich ein bisschen um die Serverseite kümmern und auch als Admin
sich ein bisschen mit Anwendungsentwicklung auseinandersetzen.
Aber das jetzt ein Frontend-Entwickler sich komplett um den Betrieb der Anwendung kümmert,
umfassend leichtet sich, weil ich weiß ja nicht wie es gemeint ist, es ist jetzt vielleicht
nicht so hundertprozentig in den Titel entsprechend oder?
Für unsere Software, für unsere Lösung setzen wir auf verschiedene Technologien folgend
ein Ausdruck aus Tech-Stacks aktueller Projekte, React.js, Vue.js, damit werdet ihr schon mal
auf viel viel Freude, Begeisterung stoßen.
Ich meine, gibt es natürlich noch bessere, krassere Hype-Frameworks jetzt, aber es muss
ja auch irgendwas sein, was Business-Technik schon etabliert ist.
Das werden auf jeden Fall genug Leute finden, die das mögen.
Auch, auch, warum nicht alles drei?
Da hätte ich jetzt ein bisschen Fragezeichen über dem Kopf.
Ob es alle drei sind?
War ich da nicht eins?
TypeScript, Tailwind, CSS, GraphQL, Node.js.
Gut, Node.js, ja klar, die ganzen Tools für Frontend sind in Node.js.
Ach, verschiedene, ach so, dafür sucht ihr Leute, okay.
Also sprich, es ist nicht so, dass ihr das, also es ist nicht so, dass ihr in einen Auftrag
kommt, entwickelt das mal für uns.
Sondern es ist eher so, dass ihr das dann auch für uns entwickelt.
Dass ihr eure Kunden unterstützt beim Entwickeln und dementsprechend auch denen ihre Infrastruktur
und Git-Server und sowas mitverwendet.
Was wir erwarten.
Von unseren neuen Kollegen erwarten wir eine proaktive und offene Kommunikation gegenüber
unseren Kunden.
Okay, ja.
Das könnt ihr auch erwarten, ist glaube ich nicht so gut, wenn das erste ist, was man
hört.
Aber warum muss ich euren Kack programmieren?
Sollte man eigentlich erwarten.
Wir suchen Entwicklerinnen mit langjähriger Erfahrung in der Umsetzung von Web-Anwendungen.
Gut, ist ja eine Senior-Stelle, vollkommen legitim.
Dabei hast du bereits Erfahrung im Internet.
Das ist übrigens auch was, was ich von der Senior-Position erwarten würde.
Deswegen finde ich es auch vollkommen richtig, das reinzuschreiben.
Eine Senior-Position würde ich auch erwarten, dass sie nicht nur fachlich gut was draufhaben,
aber auch, dass sie auch eine gute Erfahrung haben.
Dass man zumindest das zusätzlich auch noch ganz gut vertreten und verkaufen können.
Wir suchen Entwicklerinnen.
Also Senior-Leute, das ist ja auch immer jemand, wo ich sagen würde, den kann man in irgendein
übergreifendes Meeting schicken, der dann quasi die Interessen des Teams vertritt dort.
Muss ja nicht unbedingt immer der Chef machen, gerade wenn es ist was, wo man technisch ein
bisschen Ahnung haben muss.
So, das würde ich halt auch bei einer Senior-Stelle sehen.
Und ja, deswegen müssen wir ein bisschen.
Eieieiei.
Übertreib's nicht.
Ich hätte es mir auch so angeguckt.
Aber trotzdem, danke, danke.
Danke für die ganzen Subs.
Ich bin doch noch nicht fertig.
Pass mal auf.
Okay, jetzt sind die Prime-Subs drinne.
Jetzt kann ich anfangen zu flamen.
Jetzt geht's los, Leute.
Okay, lass uns kurz fertig lesen.
Wir suchen Entwicklerinnen.
Bereits Erfahrung im Enterprise-Umfeld sammeln, konnten Arbeiten gerne an komplexen...
Gut, Senior.
Agile Arbeitsweise wie Skammer, eine starke DevOps-Kultur.
Setzt du voraus und steckst diese Prozesse in Gruppen.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Bereits Erfahrung im Enterprise-Umfeld sammeln, konnten Arbeiten gerne an komplexen...
Gut, Senior.
Agile Arbeitsweise wie Skammer, eine starke DevOps-Kultur.
Setzt du voraus und steckst diese Prozesse in Kundenprojekten.
Okay.
Ähm...
Habt ihr irgendeine, habt ihr irgendeine Anforderung?
Ich mein, das ist ja eine Senior-Study, habt ihr irgendeine Anforderung an...
Irgendeine bisschen konkretere Anforderung an Erfahrung?
Ich mein, okay.
Wir suchen eine mit lange...
Ne, wobei, ich hab nix gesagt.
Ich hab nix gesagt.
Das ist eigentlich...
gut, wenn man es so ein bisschen waagelässt.
Ich glaube, das finde ich sogar
so viel besser, wie es ist.
Ihr sucht ja letztendlich Leute,
die Ahnung haben, Leute, die Plan haben.
Das kann nach 15
Jahren sein, das kann aber auch nach
5 Jahren sein.
Und die halt
ja auch die anderen Sachen alle mitbringen.
Ich finde das nicht schlecht.
Also ich finde
die Anzeige besser als das
meiste. Oh, guck mal.
Da ist ja, guck mal hier.
Live editiert, Leute.
Hoggers.
Höchst agil.
Ich hoffe,
das kommt morgen auch im Daily Scrum
dran. Und
der Task wurde im Kanban-Board
auch ordentlich verschoben dafür.
Ja, nice.
Also ich muss sagen, das ist besser als die meisten
Stellenanzeigen. Das, was ich hier erzählt habe,
ist jetzt ja wirklich nur ein bisschen
so.
So nitpicking oder so.
Bin ich insgesamt
in Ordnung. Passt.
Falls
das Einzige, was wir vielleicht
falls ihr wirklich da auch mehr ausgeben
wollt, vielleicht könnte man auch
ein bisschen mehr hinschreiben, aber ich verstehe es schon,
dass man eine Hausnummer
sagen will, dass die Leute
also ich denke mal, so die Intention
von euch war folgendes. Ihr wolltet da eine gewisse Hausnummer
hinschreiben, dass die Leute sich bewerben,
dass die Leute sehen, okay, hier gibt's
auch was zu holen.
Ihr wolltet allerdings nicht
mega das Ding hinschreiben,
dass es einen gewissen Verhandlungsspielraum
einfach gibt. So in der Richtung
stelle ich mir das vor. Und
deswegen denke ich, geht das auch so vollkommen
in Ordnung.
Also da wird eh keiner
da wird, also hoffe ich mal, eh keiner
denken, da steht ab
4500, da wird eh keiner denken
ist Schluss. Ja, da wird sich
dann halt auch jemand bewerben, der vielleicht eine Vorstellung
hat, keine Ahnung, 70k, 80k.
Und das dann sagen. Und dann kann man sich ja
der Sache ein bisschen annähern.
Genau, Patrick, sehe ich auch so.
Ich dachte am Anfang auch, ist ja nicht so viel, aber als
Verhandlungsgrundlage ist das
vollkommen super.
Nice, und danke schön für die ganzen Subs.
Ich skippe das mal.
Aber schön, Chat, dass ihr mitgemacht habt.
Wer hat eigentlich, also
die Hälfte hat wieder gedodged.
Habt ihr wieder schön die Subscriptions
evaded.
Gedodged.
Ja, bei.
Du bist wieder dran vorbei.
Vielleicht ist das auch noch was, was man
reinschreiben könnte. Teilzeit
und Vollzeit möglich. Das ist vielleicht
auch nicht verkehrt.
Das würde mich jetzt persönlich
natürlich interessieren, weil ich arbeite
ja auch nur Teilzeit.
Ich arbeite auch nur vier Tage. Also wenn das
möglich ist, ist das auch noch ein guter
Pluspunkt, den man reinschreiben kann.
Alter!
Jetzt kommt da Patrick um die Ecke. Muss er
ein Schweizer Gehalt irgendwie ausgeben.
Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs. Zehn Stück.
Nee, Beiß hat immer noch gedodged.
Wieder gedodged.
Danke für die Subs.
Poggers, hat sich heute ja wieder richtig
gelohnt zu streamen.
Komm, wir gucken uns jetzt noch irgendein interessantes
Video zum ins Bett gehen an.
22 Uhr muss ich pennen. Morgen wieder
auf die Arbeit.
So. Was können
wir uns angucken? Was haben wir zu bieten?
Intel vs. AMD.
Wer ist besser? Macht
endlich Schluss mit den Fanboys.
Alles klar.
Leute, Leute.
Ist ja gut. Ist ja gut.
Da war schon. Beiß.
Poggers. So muss das
sein.
Danke Patrick. Und Leku. Dankeschön.
Ich weiß immer noch nicht, wie man das richtig
ausspricht. Du hast mir das schon fünf Mal erzählt.
Aber
der ist Open Source. Das heißt, wir können das eh...
Ich mach Poll-Request auf.
Lügt... Lüku...
Okay, wie man da von das Ü kommen soll,
erschließt sich mir jetzt wirklich nicht.
Nice. Dankeschön. Das hier.
Wirtschaftsinformatik
Jobeinstieg.
Mein IT Startup.
Alpha Uni. Okay.
Leute, das gucken wir. Vorschlag aus
dem Chat. Da ist so viele Leute
jetzt gegiftet. Jetzt kommen wir auf einen Vorschlag aus dem Chat.
Save
Schweizer. Machen die das
so mit dem Ü?
Serious Max hat...
Das habe ich doch heute offen. Das gucken
wir uns irgendwann anders an.
Dieses angucken.
Okay, aber ganz schnell jetzt.
Wieso ist das...
Ist das was von dir?
Oder hast du was mit denen zu tun?
Okay, kein Dark Mode. Geht schon mal schlecht los.
ICT Support Engineer.
Second Level für Clouds
und IT Services.
MW.
Warum nur männlich-weiß?
Warum nicht auch noch deutsch? Ah, weil es in der Schweiz
ist. Es müsste eigentlich MWS sein.
80 bis
100?
Okay.
Ist ein dynamisches
und erfolgreiches Schweizer
IT-Unternehmen zur Verstärkung des
Support Teams für unsere stetig wachsenden Business
Cloud und IT-Service. Das suchen wir
am Standort Lupfig.
Okay, ich kenne mich in der Schweiz nicht aus,
aber davon habe ich noch nie gehört.
Ein engagiertes und motiviertes
neues Teammitglied für unseren Team Betrieb
und Support. Betriebs- und Support,
darf ich mal raten? Das sind welche, die
Schichtarbeit machen müssen und 24 7 da
sein? Ist das mit Schichtarbeit?
Falls ja, äh...
Finden das... Es wird schwierig, Leute
zu finden, die Bock drauf haben.
Kann ich euch als eigene Erfahrung von uns sagen.
Ohne Gehalt?
Ja. Weil ich gehört habe, die Schweizer machen
das mit Gehalt eigentlich ganz gerne.
So, als ICT Support.
Was ist denn ICT?
IT Communi...
Tele... Ne.
Was ist ICT?
Information
und Tele... Okay, da lag
ich doch nicht so verkehrt.
Als
ICT Support Engineer Second Level
unterstützen Sie
unseren Helpdesk und
Kunden bei Aufgaben und Störungsfällen
und überzeugen als kompetenter Ansprechpartner.
Bei Bedarf nehmen Sie
vor Ort Client-Server-Netzwerk-Systeme
in Betrieb und übernehmen vereinzelte
Tage im Helpdesk.
Oha!
No! God!
No! God! Please! No!
No! No!
Kein Helpdesk. Das würde ich...
Das wäre für mich Ausschlusskriterium.
Entweder als
Keck bei...
Da hätte ich wirklich keinen Bock drauf.
Absolut gar nicht.
Liko,
warum fragst du?
Willst du dich dort bewerben
oder arbeitest du dort?
Was ist der Hintergrund, warum du das gepostet hast?
Okay.
Sie organisieren sich selbst und sind zuständig für die...
Sie organisieren sich selbst.
Das ist auch immer so eine tolle Aussage.
Sie organisieren sich selbst und...
Ach, du arbeitest da. Okay.
Sie sind zuständig für die Qualifizierung und Priorisierung
von entgegengenommenen Stör- und Supportfällen.
Ja, okay. Hätte ich jetzt gedacht.
Diese bearbeiten Sie im Rahmen ihrer...
Kenntnisse weitgehend selbst. Okay, bla bla bla.
Bei Bedarf erhalten Sie Unterstützung von...
Okay, bla bla bla.
Weiter planen und bearbeiten Sie
Aufgaben im Rahmen von Kundenaufträgen
teilweise oder vollständig
selbst.
Dazu gehören unter anderem die Planung
im Betrieb einer neuen Kundenstandorte und das Einrichten
von Cloud... Das Einrichten von
Cloud-Lösungen. Also viel unspezifischer
kann es jetzt ja wirklich nicht mehr sein.
Das ist ja...
Ich mach was mit
Computer.
Das ist das einzige, wie du das
noch steigern kannst. Ich mach was mit Computer.
Nach ihrer
umfassenden Einarbeitung erhalten Sie...
Okay, wenn ihr das wirklich so meint, ist gut, aber...
Ich weiß das,
dass es nicht oft passiert, weil...
So was ähnliches steht dort, wo ich aktuell
arbeite, auch in der Stellenanzeige.
Und die Einarbeitung ist...
Nicht existent zum größten Teil.
Nach ihrer umfassenden Einarbeitung erhalten
Sie die Möglichkeit, schrittweise die technische
Betriebsverantwortung für verschiedene auf
Cloud-Technologien versehene Lösungen zu benötigen.
Die Betriebsverantwortung?
Du bist Support!
Warum hast du als
Support die Verantwortung für irgendwas?
Also...
Ich kenn's von uns.
Ich versuch das mal zu
umschreiben.
Ich kenn das von uns.
Wir haben ein 24-7 Support.
Bei uns.
Und die
haben auch die, wie man es so schön nennt,
Betriebsverantwortung.
Was damit allerdings nur gemeint ist,
bei uns, weiß jetzt nicht, wie es
bei euch ist,
dadurch, dass die
quasi sich um die Überwachung kümmern
und um...
Überwachung, Monitorung,
Eskalation von Störungen,
das einzige, was bei uns damit gemeint
ist, ist,
dass die Überwartungsarbeiten
dass die
Wartungsarbeiten abnicken müssen.
Die müssen informiert werden über Wartungsarbeiten
und müssen diese quasi zur Kenntnis nehmen
und abnehmen.
Viel anderes ist da bei uns damit nicht gemeint.
Weil selbstverständlich kann der Support
nicht dafür verantwortlich gemacht werden,
wenn neue Anwendungsversionen deployed werden
und wir den Bug haben. Wie soll das funktionieren?
Wie du dir einen Schichtdienst
vorstellen kannst,
meistens aus einer Kombination
Frühschicht, Tagsüberschicht
und Spätschicht, beziehungsweise
Nachtschicht.
Also sowas von, sagen wir mal,
6 bis
13 Uhr, 13 Uhr
bis irgendwie 21 Uhr
und dann, keine Ahnung, 21 Uhr
bis 6 Uhr oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Ich habe mich ein bisschen vertan mit den Zeiten wahrscheinlich,
aber sowieso in der Richtung.
Ja.
Das kann man sich betrieblich vorstellen.
Und dann wechselnd
auch. Also sprich,
dass du dann mal 3 Tage so, 3 Tage so,
3 Tage so und dann wieder ein bisschen frei
und dann wieder von vorne oder wie auch immer der Schichtplan ist.
Ist auf jeden Fall nicht für jeden was.
Okay, also nachher
Qualifikation.
Informatiker EFZ.
Das ist irgendein Schweizer Ding, ich habe keine Ahnung,
was ein EFZ-Informatiker ist.
Mit mindestens 3 Jahren Berufserfahrung
und entsprechende Quereinsteiger
breit
Was?
Breit abgestütztes
Informatik-Fachwissen
im Microsoft-System
und Cloud-Umfeld. Okay.
Eigenständige Lösungsfindung durch
analytische und strukturierte Arbeitsweise,
hohe Lernbereitschaft, rasche Auffassungsgabe,
Kenntnisse in den Bereichen Microsoft
365, Windows Server,
Client, Remote, Desktop, Gmong,
Active Directory, Virtualisierungslösungen
sowie IP-Netze. Gut,
das ist ja mal auch der komplette
Umschlag.
Virtualisierungslösung ist ein so breites Feld,
dass du dafür ganze Abteilungen haben kannst.
Genauso wie Netzwerk.
Gut, muss man dann halt
im Detail gucken, was es ist.
Freude am direkten Kundenkontakt.
No!
God!
Piss dich also!
No! No! God, please, no!
Okay, wäre für mich
schon mal...
Was ist eine Picket-Bereitschaft?
Was ist ein Picket?
Okay, das ist Schweiz. Da muss man nach
Schweiz suchen. Die Schweizer erklären...
Picket-Dienst...
Ist das doch Bereitschaft?
Was ist ein Picket?
Beim Picket-Dienst hält sich der
Arbeitnehmer oder die Arbeitnehmerin
neben der normalen Arbeit für...
Ach, Berufbereitschaft ist das!
Ach so!
Ja, das
ist nicht schlimm.
Kommt auf den Umfang an.
Nee, damit ist bestimmt
nicht 24-7 am Handy gemeint.
Also wenn das so ist,
wenn das so ist, ist...
Das ist doof. Also 24-7
am Handy bereit ist, ist doof.
Wenn das eingeteilt ist,
dass du das, was weiß ich,
so im Team, dass
irgendwie jeder mal ran muss,
zwei-, dreimal im Jahr für eine Woche,
finde ich das vollkommen in Ordnung.
Aber wenn es natürlich immer permanent ist,
dann ist es kacke.
Es ist alle sechs Wochen.
Dann könnte man vielleicht auch noch leben.
Nee,
seriously, Leute!
Je nachdem, wie gut der Laden aufgestellt ist,
ist Berufbereitschaft jetzt nicht unbedingt
so als super kritisch zu sehen.
Erstens, genau, erstens kriegt man Geld dafür
und in Deutschland ist es so, dass
Bereitschaftsgeld ein bisschen
weniger, also du musst weniger Steuern drauf
bezahlen. Und wenn der Laden gut aufgestellt ist,
sodass in der Bereitschaft so gut wie nichts passiert,
kann sich das wirklich lohnen, ohne dass es
jetzt super krasser Stress ist.
Stilsicheres Deutsch sowie
Verständigung in Englisch.
Französisch kennt er gut, wir sind in der
Schweiz. Teamorientiertes Arbeiten mit
Fahnen und Pflichtbussen.
Okay, relativ 0 auf 15.
Relativ 0 auf 15 die
Stellenanzeige. Ist jetzt nicht, wo ich sagen würde,
oh krass, muss ich machen. Also bei mir, ich wäre eh schon raus
mit Kundenkontakt
und sowas, aber
Helpdesk.
Leute, komm, wir gucken uns jetzt schnell das Video noch an.
Meint ihr, wir schaffen das noch?
Achtung.
Komm, wir haben ein bisschen, im Zweifelsfall überziehen,
wir, im Zweifelsfall überziehen wir.
Ziehen wir ein bisschen. Also,
Wirtschaftsinformatik-Jobeinstieg, mein IT-Startup.
App in den
App-Store abbringen. Ich bin jetzt schon
seit zwei Stunden hier und es
ist schon einiges schief gegangen.
Und es funktioniert immer noch nicht.
Ähnlich bei jemandem, die richtige Informatiker-Figur.
Das heißt, das war schon mal nicht der Fehler.
Wir wollen
möglich machen, dass der Trainer jeden ansprechen
kann. Philipp, ich hab gesagt,
du sollst tief laufen. Alter, ist ja gut.
Morgen, KS. Hast du verstanden, was der will? Dir ist die
Weste des Spielers
darin ein kleiner
Lautsprecher verbaut.
Er hat jetzt hier einen Fehler geschmissen. Normalerweise würde
die App jetzt abstürzen. Beim Programmieren
sitzt das Problem auch vor dem
vor dem Bildschirm.
Normalerweise würde die App jetzt
abstürzen, ja nur, wenn es in C++ programmiert ist.
Wie sieht denn das aus
von den Einrückungen her, Leute?
Ich sehe da
keine Klammern. Könnte
das... Nee, das ist nicht... Für
Python ist es ein bisschen viel, ein bisschen
komisch gestaffelt.
Was ist denn das? Jemand eine Ahnung? Rein von der...
Kann man nicht wirklich gut erkennen,
gell? Eigentlich, das ist
HTML.
Das... Das sieht, finde
ich, nicht so sehr wie
HTML aus.
Wir haben leider das Problem,
dass die Plätze gesperrt sind.
Es ist Druck da, aber ich kann damit
sehr gut umgehen, auf jeden Fall.
Hallo Leute, ich bin Julian. Es ist Druck da. Nice.
Mitgründer und Geschäftsführer
eines Sporttechnologie-Startups
und wir wollen
unser Produkt nächste Woche
releasen. Das heißt, wir wollen eine App
in den App-Store bringen. Da ist sehr
viel zu tun und ob wir das schaffen,
erfahrt ihr in diesem Video.
Die Planung ist schon mal merkwürdig.
Eine Woche vor Release?
Sind die noch voll
in der Entwicklung? Eine Woche
vor Release solltest du eigentlich...
Okay, ich rede jetzt nicht von der Realität,
ja, ich geb's zu, aber eine Woche
vor Release solltest du eigentlich soweit fertig
sein, dass du wirklich nur noch Detailanpassungen brauchst,
wenn überhaupt.
Und nicht noch voll in der...
Ich bin jetzt schon seit zwei
Stunden hier und es ist schon einiges
schiefgegangen. Zuerst ist halt
Schneechaos hier in Jena und in der
Umgebung. Das heißt, einige
Mitarbeiter, unter anderem
der, unser Chef-Ingenieur
für die Hardware, konnte
heute leider nicht hier mit ins Büro kommen.
Dann... Stehtisch. Gab's
Moment, das ist kein... Ist das ein höhenverstellbarer Tisch?
Ja, oder?
Aber das ist ein Mini, Mini-Büro.
Mini-Büro. Aber gut, ich meine
Start-up-Stells, ja?
...mit ins Büro kommen, dann
gab's vorhin einen kleinen
Fehler, wo die neuesten Änderungen
nicht mit der IOS-Version kompatibel waren.
Das konnte man zum Glück lösen.
Das wundert mich ja mal gar nicht.
Es steht halt, wie gesagt, an
die Hälfte der Tickets schaffen.
Es ist nicht leicht, aber
ich hab ja auch ein großartiges Team,
das mir dabei hilft und ich bin mir sicher,
dass wir diese Herausforderung schaffen können.
Das hat...
Das hat er im Business...
im Business-Rhetorik-Kurs gelernt.
Er guckt auch schon so.
Er guckt auch schon so. Das hab ich jetzt
so gesagt, weil ich's im Rhetorik-Kurs gelernt habe.
Da muss er noch ein bisschen überzeugender bringen können.
Okay.
Unsere Idee war es,
ein Kommunikationssystem für den Profisport
zu entwickeln.
Ich hab gesagt, du sollst tief laufen!
Hast du verstanden, was der will?
Wir wollen möglich machen,
dass der Trainer jeden ansprechen kann
und das frei, wie er will.
So mit uns.
Die Idee klingt eigentlich echt cool.
Mich würde allerdings wundern,
wenn es das nicht schon gäbe.
Kann er einfach einen Spieler ansprechen,
den es betrifft
und auch in Gruppen,
was mit unserem Tool besser möglich ist.
Das war unsere Vision.
Hier ist die
Weste des Spielers.
Darin
ein kleiner Lautsprecher verbaut.
Da steht hier, möchtest du einen Tracker zugewiesen bekommen?
Ja, verbinden.
Dann leuchtet ein Tracker auf.
Ich finde die Idee cool.
Mich würde es nur wundern, wenn es da nicht schon etablierte Systeme
für gibt.
Der kann jetzt entfernt werden.
Muss es nur noch in seine Weste stecken
und dann ist man ready to go.
Und er kann angesprochen werden.
Die letzte Komponente ist natürlich die App.
Wie es ja heute auch geht.
Die hat der Trainer in der Hand
und da kann der Trainer seinen Spieler sehen.
Ich bin hier sowohl als Geschäftsführer,
also im Managementbereich tätig,
als auch hier als CTO
auch im operativen Bereich.
Neben meiner Programmiertätigkeit
verhandle ich auch mit Investoren,
mit Industriepartnern, mit Lieferanten
und natürlich
habe ich auch Personaleinscheidungsgewalt.
Er steht erstmal dahinter und guckt noch
ob er das ordentlich schafft.
Er macht einen äußerst sympathischen Eindruck.
Der Innenminister.
Da kannst du dich jetzt darüber streiten,
ob er sich CTO oder CEO.
Aber ich finde, er macht einen sympathischen Eindruck.
So eine Struktur.
Mein Mitgründer, der Philipp,
das ist unser Außenminister.
Der macht Marketing, Vertrieb,
alles diese Themen und alles, was nach innen geht.
Da bin ich der Ansprechpartner.
Die haben einen BWLer, das reicht schon.
Jetzt ist klar, was wir brauchen,
dass wir das so verfeinern,
dass das Failsafe ist.
Das heißt, der Nutzer so wenig wie möglich
Fehler machen kann,
die die App für ihn nicht mehr nutzen kann.
Einfach alles über Skype.
Ich zeige euch jetzt, was genau das Problem ist.
Und zwar hier in unserem Live-Modus
hat der Trainer die Möglichkeit,
sich individuelle Gruppen zu machen.
Und zwar hier kann er einfach Spiele auswählen
und in eine Gruppe ziehen.
Wenn eine Gruppe
jetzt hier gelöscht wird,
dann erscheinen die Spieler
in der Spielerliste.
Da müssen sie wohl kündigen
und neue Spieler kaufen.
Jetzt habe ich einen Versuch gemacht,
was das Problem meiner Meinung nach
beheben könnte.
Das muss ich jetzt testen.
Dafür spiele ich gerade die App
nochmal neu drauf.
Ja, wenn das Testen von IOS
Sachen nicht so abfuckt wäre.
Ich melde mich wieder an.
Ich habe gerade die Daten geladen.
Hier.
Screen.
Ja, Leute, Leute.
Automatisierte Tests kommen dann nach Release.
Jetzt muss erstmal die App fertig werden.
Das heißt,
die automatisierten Tests kommen nie.
Machen wir uns mal wieder eine Gruppe voll.
Muss Prioritäten setzen im Startup.
Dass das hier immer noch geht.
Es ist auch immer wichtig,
immer die Sachen zu testen,
die funktionieren sollen schon.
Dass man die immer mal wieder mittestet.
Weil oft ist es auch so, dass Änderungen,
die man im Code macht, an einer anderen Stelle
nicht mehr da sind.
Ich vergleiche das immer gerne
mit so einem Jahrmarktspiel,
was man vielleicht kennt,
wo man diese Maulwürfe runterhauen muss.
Und wenn man einen Maulwurf runterhaut,
erscheinen manchmal einfach drei neue.
Und genauso ist das auch beim Programmieren.
Jetzt löschen wir diese Gruppe.
Es sind sechs Spieler hier drin,
vier Spieler hier.
Wie heißt das auf Deutsch?
Regressionstesten?
Regression?
Gibt es das Wort überhaupt?
Leute!
Ihr habt den falschen Ansatz.
Ihr erzählt hier irgendwas von Tests
oder Dokumentation
oder Kommentare oder sowas.
Es ist ganz einfach.
Ab jetzt muss er einfach
fehlerfrei programmieren.
Er hat festgestellt,
dass er fertig ist.
Und jetzt muss er zu seinem Team gehen
und sagen, ab jetzt machen wir keine Fehler mehr.
Nächste Woche ist Release.
Und alles, was ihm nicht gefällt,
einfach nicht benutzen.
Das haben wir heute auch gelernt.
Einfach nicht benutzen.
Just do it.
Das sind ja immer einzelne Lines of Code.
Und man muss halt genau da finden,
wo der Fehler entstehen könnte,
was da falsch übergeben wird,
weil das sind ja alles Variablen.
Das hat sich ja entwickelt.
Jetzt erkennen wir es.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall kein HTML.
Das funktioniert.
Du musst nur genug dran glauben.
Dann funktioniert das vielleicht auch.
In Rust wäre das wenigstens
blazingly fast.
Was? Der Bart?
Welcher Bart?
Das ist bei ihm so ein ganz normaler Bart.
Das sind Variablen,
die halt von dem einen,
also hier in diesem Fall sind Spieler,
und genau das versuche ich halt
im Code zu finden.
Und wenn ich das gefunden habe,
dann muss man auch zwei, dreimal probieren.
Das ist ein Try-and-Error-Prinzip,
um dann zu gucken, welche Änderung da gewirkt hat.
Dann melden wir uns wieder an.
Guter Mann.
Genauso hätte ich es auch gesagt.
Ohne Scheiß.
Ich will mich da nicht drüber lustig machen.
Genauso hätte ich es auch gesagt.
Dann muss man dann gucken,
welche Änderung da gewirkt hat.
1 zu 1 hätte so im Stream
sagen können. Müssen wir gucken,
was gewirkt hat.
Der ist richtig drin, das merkt man.
Gehen wieder auf unseren Screen zurück.
Auch hier wieder derselbe Flow wie vorhin.
Wir packen wieder ein paar Spieler
hier in die Gruppe.
Ich habe vorhin schon gesehen,
dass es nicht reagiert hat,
an genau der gleichen Stelle.
Ist euch das auch aufgefallen?
Das letzte Mal, als er den mittleren Typ
selecten wollte,
hat es auch schon gebackt.
Was ist das für eine Sprache?
Ich habe es jetzt nicht gesehen.
Wahrscheinlich Swift, wenn es iOS-Zeug ist.
Oder sie wollen es
rausbringen für Android.
Cross-Plattform vielleicht.
Ist auch irgendwie Javascript-Zeug.
Aber wahrscheinlich Swift.
Objective-C ist das.
Meinst du ernsthaft,
es gibt sich jemand?
Guck, habt ihr es gesehen?
Der mittlere ist immer kaputt.
Oder der Finger.
Packen wieder ein paar Spieler hier in die Gruppe.
Mal schauen, ob das noch läuft.
Gehen wieder rein.
Und löschen die Gruppe.
Jetzt habt ihr was gesehen,
was auch ab und zu mal vorkommen kann.
Und zwar habe ich jetzt hier was eingebaut,
was
nicht funktioniert.
Das heißt, er hat jetzt hier einen Fehler geschmissen.
Das Logo erinnert mich ein bisschen
an das Logo vom CT-Magazin.
Die App jetzt abstürzen.
Und das ist,
wie so oft beim Programmieren,
ist jetzt das Problem.
Manchmal auch vor dem Bildschirm.
Und genau, das muss ich jetzt nochmal...
Pep-Kack. Ist das dann?
Pep-Kack.
Problem exists between
between keyboard and chair?
Ne, between screen and chair?
Oder wie geht das? Pep-Kack?
Korrekt machen.
Dann mache ich hier
crazy Programmier-Magic.
Kurz warten, bis alle Daten geladen sind.
Wir wollen hier,
dass hier 10 steht.
Funktioniert.
Heute stehen noch 15 Tickets an.
Erstmal eine Runde Football spielen.
Das ist bestimmt auch ein 24-Stunden-Job aktuell.
Wenn man was erreicht,
dann hat man diese Erfolgserlebnisse.
Das pusht einen natürlich auch.
Man hat aber auch viele schlaflose Nächte,
wo man halt einfach drüber nachdenkt,
wie könnte man das machen, wie könnte man das machen.
Manchmal mache ich mitten in der Nacht auf
und dann kann ich das lösen.
Schreibe mir das auf, schlafe weiter
und am nächsten Tag versuche ich das umzusetzen.
Also ich glaube, der macht aktuell nicht viel anderes,
als sich um die Firma zu kümmern.
Das ist halt der richtig harte Startup-Crime.
Also es kommen immer ungeplante Sachen.
Es kommen immer Sachen, die man unterschätzt hat.
Was meint der erst, was los ist,
wenn das Ding released ist,
es Leute gekauft haben
und irgendwas nicht funktioniert, Alter.
Das wird der pure Abfang, Mann.
Wie gesagt, die waren ein größeres Problem,
die dann doch nicht so ein großes Problem wurden.
Und ja,
man entwickelt sich
Schritt für Schritt mit dem Produkt.
In den Vorlesungen wurde behandelt,
wie man theoretisch so Projektmanagement macht
und dann halt in der Praxis wurde das auch umgesetzt.
Solche Praxisprojekte ist auch das,
was mir am meisten aus der Uni geholfen hat,
überhaupt erst den Transfer
in diesen Arbeitskontext zu schaffen.
Chad, ihr wisst doch überhaupt nicht,
ob das nicht doch Cloud-Native ist?
Wir haben jetzt
die iOS-App gesehen, die ist bestimmt
nicht Cloud-Native.
Wie soll eine iOS-App Cloud-Native sein?
Aber das Backend kann doch durchaus
High-IQ,
Buzzword-Bullshit-Bingo Cloud-Native sein.
In der Hinsicht Informatik ist es so,
dass sich einzelne Module dort
sehr lohnenswert waren. Mein Wirtschaftshintergrund,
also alles, was ich
über Marketing dort
gelernt habe oder
über Gesellschaftsformen,
über Controlling, über
Budgetierung, über Buchhaltung,
das sind alles Sachen,
die ich auch heute
reell anwenden kann.
Ich habe auch Buchhaltung gelernt.
Und es gibt sicherlich noch
einige Sachen, die ich davon könnte.
Ich kann zum Beispiel
die Buchhalternase noch,
ich weiß, das habe ich schon 500 Mal erzählt,
und ich weiß, dass man,
ich habe schon wieder vergessen, was,
linear und degressiv abschreiben kann.
Aber ich will damit
absolut nichts mehr zu tun haben.
Degressiv ist nicht mehr,
ja gut, ist schon ein bisschen her.
Ist schon ein bisschen her.
Keine Ahnung, ob das noch,
das kann sein, dass es nicht mehr geht.
Heute kommt zusätzlich
noch eine Studie auf dem
Feld, also mit unseren Sportwissenschaftlern
und das steht dann heute Nachmittag an.
Also es ist wieder alles voller Tickets
und wir versuchen wieder so viel wie möglich
heute umzusetzen, damit Freitag alles klar geht.
Jawoll.
Hier haben wir unsere Sportwissenschaftler,
geleitet wird das Team von Rami.
Die sind genau heute für diese Studie verantwortlich.
Dort wird eben
der Einfluss unseres Systems
Das Video mit dem Florian gibt es noch nicht.
Der Florian hat ein bisschen mit YouTube zu kämpfen gehabt,
aber wir machen das demnächst.
Patrick, ehrlich gesagt,
bei mir ist es nicht so wie bei euch
in dem Umfang, aber
genau das habe ich auch gemacht.
Das erste, als ich damals die Firma gegründet habe,
ich meine, es ist eine Ein-Mann-Firma, aber
ich sage es jetzt einfach mal so,
als ich die Firma gegründet habe,
ist mir ein Steuerberater gesucht.
Und es fuckt mich jetzt schon ab,
wenn ich das einmal im Jahr alles ausfüllen muss.
Genau so.
Ich hoffe, dass
erstmal alles gut läuft mit unserer
Planung, was wir in den letzten Wochen
geplant haben
und dann wir auch die Erhobenen
bekommen. Dann können wir dem Trainer
auch wissenschaftlich bewiesen, dass zum Beispiel
mit unserem System
die Trainingseinheiten leichter durchgeführt
werden, wird Zeit gespart
und die Spieler werden auch
Es ist halt die Frage, ob das den Trainer
überzeugt.
Es ist alles die Frage, wie sie ihm das verkaufen.
Zumal ja vielleicht der Trainer gar nicht derjenige ist,
der das entscheidet.
Okay, was ist die Webseite
von denen? Okay, Sekunde, machen wir mal kurz auf.
coachwhisperer.de
Okay, die Seite ist definitiv nicht
written in Rust Blazingly Fast.
Ah, jetzt geht's, okay.
Except, das sieht so wie
eine typische Webseite mit
mit, wie weiß ich, wie sich das
nennt, so diese typische aktuelle
Landingpage.
Die sieht aus wie ein Sport-BH.
Ja, bisschen vielleicht, ja.
Sieht aus wie so eine typische
Landingpage
von
Eigentlich ist die Seite gut, die
fühlt sich sehr responsive
an und
Okay, mal gucken, ob die responsive ist.
Erstmal kurz gucken, ob die Seite responsive
ist. Oh, die Seite ist...
halbwegs responsive.
Die Seite ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Das ist mein Bereich,
unser IT-Büro. Da gehen wir jetzt mal rein.
Die kommen aus dem Baukasten.
Ist doch nicht wild.
Er selber beschreibt
seinen Job immer so,
dass er für alles verantwortlich ist, was
einen Stecker oder einen Akku hat.
Naja, wie geht's mir? Also, ich sag mal so, wir
sind so auf der Zielgeraden,
dass wir tausend Wege führen nach oben,
um so zu sagen. Also, so kleine Stolperstände
gibt's ja immer. Aber so, ähm,
bleibt spannend, jeden Tag aufregend.
Ich schalte ja auch zu Hause kaum noch ab.
Ich träume manchmal davon, sag ich mal.
Versteh ich. Wenn ich den ganzen Tag
Zeug gemacht hab, träum ich auch manchmal. Den übertriebensten
Schwachsinn. Die ganze Nacht vor der Schaltung
gesessen hab, dann verfolgt mich das in meinen Träumen
noch, wo irgendwelche Leitungen langliegen.
Kenn ich.
Es herrscht große Anspannung.
Julian, kann ich dich mal ganz kurz sprechen?
Es geht um das Testing heute.
Geben wir euch
nicht so auf den Senkel.
Der Robert hat mich gerade angerufen.
Wir haben doch
für die doch schon
die Lösung, Chad.
Wir sollten uns da wirklich mal als Consultants anbieten.
Einfach nicht testen.
Wegen des Tests heute, wegen der Studie, wir haben leider
das Problem, dass die Plätze
gesperrt sind. Aufgrund des
Schneefalls.
Ich hab ihn gefragt, ob wir vielleicht noch eine Halle finden.
Er hat gesagt, dass das Testing stattfinden kann.
Wenn es in der Halle geht,
da ist ja auch gleich die Laufe
daneben.
Es wäre für unsere Studie super wichtig,
dass wir weiterhin testen können.
Wir setzen jetzt gerade alles irgendwie daran,
dass der Termin heute stattfinden kann.
Versprechen können wir uns natürlich nicht aktuell.
Es kann ja nicht immer alles
glatt gehen, sag ich mal.
Man ist halt nicht Herr übers Wetter.
Daran muss man einfach konstruktiv bleiben.
Es bringt nichts zu verzweifeln.
Das ist auch einer
der großen Stärken unseres großen Teams
und unserer Firma. Wir finden
für alles immer Lösungen.
Die sind dann vielleicht nicht die...
Ich muss es noch
überzeugender bringen.
Plan A, aber wir finden für alles Lösungen.
Und dass
ich das jetzt hier so sagen darf,
das macht mich unglaublich stolz.
Ich glaube ihm das sogar.
Es klang halt nur nicht so
komplett überzeugend.
Der Robert hat jetzt nochmal angerufen.
Wir finden leider keine Halle für heute.
Deswegen müssen wir den heutigen
Test leider absagen.
Meint ihr, dass es da wirklich passiert
oder es ist gestellt an dem Tag,
dass die quasi mal reale Situationen
filmen können?
Es ist Druck da.
Es ist Druck da, aber
ich kann damit sehr gut umgehen, auf jeden Fall.
Ich arbeite sehr viel.
Das will ich nicht verheimlichen.
Als Gründer ist das immer so, dass man
nie die 40 Stunden einhält.
Ich habe eher 1,5 Buffers,
zweifach so viel, aber
ich habe nie Schwierigkeiten
früh aus dem Bett aufzustehen und
hierher zu kommen, weil ich lebe
in meinem Traum.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Mit so einer Tastatur könnte ich auch nicht
gescheit programmieren.
Guckt euch mal das Ding an, Mann.
Das ist so eine Mini
Flat-Ding.
Da stehen die Apple-Leute vielleicht drauf,
aber ich mag die gar nicht.
Der Upload hat begonnen.
Ja klar, weil der Uploader jetzt auch irgendwie
da mit so einem Progress-Balken
45 Minuten läuft, Mann.
Das war ein Flutsch oder ist das Ding
abgeloadet?
Endlich haben wir es geschafft.
Bäm.
App ist hochgeladen.
Wir freuen uns riesig.
Ja, die App alleine bringt ja nichts.
Die Leute müssen ja die Hardware dazu kaufen.
Die Überprüfung dauert wahrscheinlich jetzt
zwei bis drei Wochen, bis sie dann auch für alle
Kunden kommen.
Wir haben alles gegeben und jetzt
kann sie released werden.
Wenn ihr wissen wollt, wie das Studium wird...
Das erste Mal Kundenkontakt.
Okay Leute, das gucken wir jetzt mal.
Ein Moment, der
irgendwie
einen sehr mitnimmt.
Wenn man auf sowas
keinen Bock hat.
Kundenkontakt ist das Schlimmste.
Also End-User.
Ja, so normal.
Normaler Kundenkontakt so in Form von
ich muss
mit dem Telekom Support telefonieren
oder sowas. Das ist kein Ding.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Die leben halt aktuell
gerade 24
7 für ihr Produkt.
Beziehungsweise für
ihren Laden.
Das kannst du auch nicht ewig machen.
Gut, das ist ein
anderer Punkt. Du hast vielleicht recht.
Da kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Das stimmt schon. Wahrscheinlich
sind die ratzfatz
weg und irgendwie
gesellt oder so dann.
Aber so rein von technologischer Seite
und was wir da gezeigt haben, fand ich
gegen den Laden komplett in Ordnung.
Außerdem gibt es dann eh einen Day One Patch.
Sobald die erste Hardware ausgeliefert wird.
Okay Leute, jetzt ist es aber wirklich
spät.
Jetzt muss ich pennen.
Wir sehen uns morgen.
Alles klar, bis dann Leute. Macht's gut. See you.